clinton les bureaux de vote viennent de
fermer à los angeles c'est bientôt le
soleil le jour se lève à paris en plein
confinement bienvenue sur fear alive
heureux heureux de vous retrouver pour
suivre cette présidentielle américaine
présidentielle pleine de suspense et on
va suivre en direct les résultats ceux
qui ne sont pas encore tombés les
résultats qui sont serrés dans plusieurs
états des états pivots de swing states
et on va suivre ça avec charlotte
barillon de bruit bonjour charlotte
bonjour vincent bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver effectivement en direct
sur figaro life pursuit poursuivre cette
matinale américaine vos commentaires vos
réactions nous intéresse ensemble nous
allons suivre et analyser les lycées les
résultats de cette élection qu'on dit
historique
pour l'instant on n'a pas le nom du
vainqueur on leur a peut-être avant la
fin de cette édition spéciale qui sait
nous verrons ça avec philippe gelie qui
étaient en plateau avec nous aujourd'hui
bonjour philippe jeudy vous êtes
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro éditorialistes international vous
avez écrit déjà deux éditos pour cette
élection peut être un troisième en
entendant la nouvelle
hume que vous êtes en train de préparer
que vous pouvez retrouver déjà vous
pouvez déjà retrouver les éditions pdf
sur le site du figaro et vous êtes l'ex
correspondant du figaro avec à
washington et vous aviez suivi
d'élections surprise déjà de trump en
2016 oui nous serons également pardon
philippe avec renault fier bonjour
renault on va vous retrouver
régulièrement au cours de cette édition
spéciale
nous verrons avec vous les dernières
estimations les dernières tendances de
ce scrutin
et justement on emmenait ou à l'instant
où je vous parle
bonjour charlotte baut jean-vincent
voulant felipe bonjour à tous trois
enseignements principaux à 6h déjà aucun
compte peut revendiquer la victoire vous
l'avez dit et regardez au moment où je
vous parle la carte que vous pouvez voir
sur lefigaro.fr ses 131 grands électeurs
pour joe biden 131 pour donald trump
avec une carte vous allez voir où tout
est extrêmement serré et c'est le
premier enseignement
les démocrates les plus enthousiastes
espérait un raz-de-marée bleus et ce
n'est pas du tout ce que nous disent les
six premiers chiffres en tout cas
extrêmement serré bien c'est donald
trump qui vire en tête
exemple en floride où il a trois points
d'avance en caroline du nord où il a un
petit peu moins de 2 points d'avance en
géorgie la houle à une solide avance de
10 points mais attention car il y a
encore beaucoup de bulletins à
dépouiller les démocrates espéraient
aussi un gros coup ici au texas à 3
heures du matin c'était d'ailleurs
l'égalité parfaite on se demandait si ça
allait être la première surprise de la
soirée puis au fur et à mesure que les
dépouillements ont continué donald trump
a pris de l'avancé et maintenant ils
creusent l'écart il a presque cinq
points d'avance le deuxième enseignement
c'est que l'arizona va probablement
passer du camp républicain au camp
démocrate l'arizona
elle est ici c'est un état frontalier
avec le mexique
alors là c'est vraiment un coup dur pour
l'équipe trump parce que le camp
démocrate va rafler les grands
les onze grands électeurs de cet état et
c'est un coup dur pour l'équipe trump
parce que l'équipe honda pour l'instant
pas créer la surprise inverse vous savez
en raflant un état qui était pour
l'instant aux mains des démocrates mais
vous l'avez compris 2020 est une année
différente les républicains jouent en
défense ils n'ont qu'à conserver tous
les autres états qui l'ont gagné en 2016
et puis trump restera à la maison
blanche c'est ce qui m'amène au
troisième et dernier enseignement
tout se jouera probablement dans les
trois états du midwest qui avait fait
basculer l'élection en 2016 je voulais
montre un whisky gin michigan et
pennsylvanie trois états qui sont autour
de la région des grands lacs trois états
qui étaient habituellement démocrate
meco trump avait emporté dans un
mouchoir de poche
il y a quatre ans est la seule
différence avec les états dont je vous
parlais un petit peu plus tôt c'est que
dans ces trois états joe biden était
donné favori avec une très large marge
d'avancé sur donald trump
alors les sondeurs auront-ils raison le
dépouillement continue mais vous l'avez
compris la matinée va être longue
alors la matinée tendre avec vous
charlotte
merci beaucoup renault pour cette
intervention vous retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour de nouvelles informations
de nouvelles estimations qui vont tomber
au fur et à mesure des minutes qui
s'écoulent
on est maintenant en plateau avec
philippe gelie vincent roux je vous
laisse la main merci beaucoup charlotte
philippe vous avez passé la nuit à
regarder les résultats vous aviez vécu
on a dit l'élection surprise de donald
trump est ce que vous pressentez que ça
peut être comparable
ce matin pour l'instant ça ressemble
beaucoup à la nuit de 2016 en effet le
il est clair que la vague bleue entre
guillemets qu'espéraient les démocrates
n'a pas n'existe pas ou en tout cas si
elle existe elle est c'est une petite
vague
il est clair que le socle républicain
est solide et large pour l'instant avec
presque 100 % des bulletins décomptés en
floride
traoré 3% d'avancé beaucoup c'est
beaucoup pour la floride la floride
votent en général avec un ennemi %
d'écart et la moyenne des sondages
pardon je vous coupe de real clear
politics qui est un des agrégateurs de
son d'arrêt ait connu les plus réputés
aux états unis de données
si mes souvenirs sont plutôt une avance
à joe biden ou et enfin il est donné au
coude à coude
on en verra mais bon c'est pas choquant
en soi que donald trump gagne la floride
la floride a voté pour les républicains
qui ont constamment depuis 2000 donc
depuis vingt ans mais par des marges
plus étroites qu'aujourd'hui apparemment
un autre exemple où le site que vous
citez qui ne fait que l'agrégation des
sondages donc une moyenne mais sur
l'ohio c'est choquant parce que on était
à + 1 % pop pour trump il ya quelques
heures dans les derniers sondages
et là on est pratiquement à huit points
d'avance pour trains actuellement le
décompte n'est pas fini le dépouillement
n'est pas terminé mais clairement il y a
eu des analyses erronées
les états au niveau de hauts niveaux de
l'ohio ont dit notamment que par exemple
dans les chais les syndicalistes et en
particulier chez les fameux col bleu
donc ses électeurs blancs populaire
trump conserve largement son avance
rien que ça c'est peut-être aussi un
échec sur le pari de bail d'hommes qui
était le candidat des cols bleus enfin
de quand il se présentait avec obama oui
certes joe biden a fait un peu toute sa
carrière sur ce sur cette image de
lui-même à sénateurs issus des milieux
populaires et qui c'est qui qui a une
jeunesse assez proche de celle des
milieux ouvriers et qui sait leur parler
cela dit il est là pour le coup les
sondages n'avait n'avait pas vraiment
montré que train de reculer auprès de
cet électorat ce que nous annonce et les
sondages c'était plutôt un recul dans
les banlieues blanches entre guillemets
classes moyennes élevées
éduquer des gens qui sont allés à
l'université au moins au premier en
premier cycle et en particulier chez les
électrices chez les femmes c'est
possible on le saura lorsqu'on aura les
résultats des grandes banlieues autour
d'atlanta au tour de ville de
pennsylvanie pittsburgh et philadelphie
mais ça n'est pas certain du tout vu
l'état la position nous sommes
aujourd'hui à cette heure ci dans le
dépouillement
avec des états qui ont 100 à 80 85 % des
bulletins dépouillés et une position
quand même une assise très solide de
trême toujours une asus tracé d'autres
pays je voulais juste voir avec vous
pour que le nos internautes qui trouve
effectivement cette élection
présidentielle passionnant mais aussi
également complexe parce qu'elle n'est
pas du tout le mode de scrutin américain
n'est pas du tout celui de la france on
sait que aux états unis on peut perdre
en ayant plus de voix est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler un peu comment marchent les
scrutins américain oui bien sûr c'est un
état fédéral donc on vote dans chaque
état d'ailleurs chaque état est libre
d'organiser le mode de scrutin
à sa façon et le dépouillement et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une grande diversité et
c'est pour ça que par exemple en ce
moment en pennsylvanie ils ont l'air de
dire qu à philadelphie il arrête le
dépouillement se soit ils reprendront
demain
pareil en géorgie enfin bon donc il ya
un potentiel de déséquilibre entre
l'arrivée dans l'arrivée des résultats
selon les états le vote populaire
c'est comme chez nous si vous voulez une
voix un électeur et si on ne comptait
que le vote populaire
il suffirait de faire campagne en
californie dans l'état de new york et en
floride et on gagnerait l'élection
américaine parce que c'est un état
fédéral et parce que tous les états y
compris des états un peu plus ruraux et
ce qu'on appelle le fly over america
c'est à dire l'amérique qu'on survole en
général surtout quand on est un touriste
et qu'on va de new york à los angeles
cette amérique là doit compter si on ne
comptait que les voix n existerait pas
des états comme le wyoming
grand comme la moitié de la france où il
ya cinq cent mille habitants et 3
seulement grands électeurs et encore ils
le doivent au fait que tous les états en
deux sénateurs il faut savoir il faut
rappeler à nos auditeurs que le nombre
de grands électeurs
c'est la somme des sénateurs et des
représentants de chaque état au congrès
donc le wyoming à un représentant parce
qu'il n'a que cinq cent mille habitants
mais il a deux sénateurs comme tous les
états donc il a trois représentants le
texte à cent à 38 la floride 29 etc et
bien sûr donc on peut gagner l'élection
américaine par le jeu du collège
électoral en perdant le vote populaire
c'est plus facile à faire pour un
républicain que pour un démocrate
le déséquilibre que j'ai expliquées
entre les états ruraux et les états plus
peuplés qui sont sur les côtes fait que
on estime que pour qu'un démocrate
partent à égalité sur le collège
électoral
il faut qu'ils les deux pour cent du
vote populaire en plus de son rival par
rapport à ce que vous dites si je te
donnerai là je vous donnerai parole
vincent dans quelques secondes mais
c'était
ceux qui attaquent ce mode de scrutin en
disant qu'il n'est pas démocratique
ça veut dire qu'ils ont tort par rapport
à la démonstration vous avez fait non
enfin il ce mode de scrutin à un effet
de distorsion sur la démocratie au sens
où on l'entend nous mais qui est
parfaitement explicables et peut-être
justifiable s'il y avait il ya eu trois
fois un vote populaire distinct du vote
du collège électoral depuis 20 ans si ça
devenait une habitude ou une une loi
intangible peut-être que il y aurait un
problème est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles ça se peut se produire c'est
aussi à cause de la règle bien connue du
winner takes all c'est à dire que vous
pouvez gagner un état gagnant le gagnant
toute la mise
exemple de train en 2016 qui gagne le le
riche le risque en scène ou au michigan
avec 0 3% davance il obtient tous les
grands électeurs de l'état ça c'est
quelque chose que les états pourraient
décider de changer s'il s'avérait que la
distorsion dont vous parlez devenait
trop systématique ou trop ou trop grande
à l'instant claudius qui est un
internaute du figaro qui nous suit
depuis le début de cette matinale
électorale et qui nous a suivis surtout
le figaro donc plus tu vas également
tout ce que vous avez relaté sur le
le live text du figaro nous dit les
sondeurs se sont encore trompés
j'ajoute qu'en pennsylvanie par exemple
pour l'instant selon edison resserre crh
trump est donné en tout cas avec une
avance de plus de quasiment plus de 10
points 14 points sur quel pourcentage
alors il ya 54 % des bleus on est loin
du résultat et on est loin du résultat
il ya un phénomène de qu'on a documenté
pendant la campagne qu'on a expliqué et
qui est particulièrement actif en
pennsylvanie parce que le vote par
correspondance a été très important et
en pennsylvanie on peut accepter les
bulletins qui arrivent encore jusqu'au 6
novembre
et on peut les décomptes et jusqu'au 12
donc il peut se produire un phénomène
que les experts américains ont appelé le
blue shift et même le raid mirage
c'est à dire que les votes décomptés le
jour du scrutin peuvent donner
l'avantagé aux candidats républicains et
sachant que les démocrates ont plus voté
par correspondance et que leurs
bulletins seront comptait plus tard il
pourrait y avoir ce basculement bleus
donc soyons prudents sur la pennsylvanie
mais la pennsylvanie promet d'être très
serrée et probablement l'état qui peut
faire tiquer faiseur de roi en l'espèce
il avait été fait leurs devoirs on vous
parlait à l'instant de ce vote par
anticipation qui a été massif cette
année
on peut l'expliquer d'une façon concrète
ce qui a mobilisé autant les gens
allaient faire une démarche qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude de faire dans
ce scrutin présidentiel lors très
dépendants des états il ya des états de
l'ouest par exemple leur ego ou le
l'état de washington qui ont
pratiquement institutionnaliser le vote
par correspondance c'est le mode de
scrutin principal est quasi exclusif
dans certains états qui sont très
minoritaires
mais évidemment cette année il ya eu
d'épidémie de cofidis mme donc beaucoup
d'états ont tenu compte de deux des
règles et consignes de sanitaires du
fait que les embouteillages dans les
bureaux de vote où les longues files
d'attentes pourrait poser un problème et
donc beaucoup d'états une majorité 30
trentaine d'états ont modifié leurs mots
leurs règles d'organisation du scrutin
pour faciliter le vote par
correspondance
certains ponts envoyé à tous les
électeurs des avis leur disant vous
pouvez voter par correspondance
d'autres sont allés plus loin et ont
même envoyé aux électeurs les bulletins
ce contre quoi cette élevé donald trump
en estimant que ça c'était de la triche
il fallait pas faire ça comme les
démocrates sont plutôt dans des états
plutôt citadins plutôt exposé au co vide
plutôt conscient des des règles de
sécurité qu'il faudrait respecter par
rapport à des électeurs plus ruraux qui
peuvent aller voter dans le bureau de
vote de leur compte et en sachant qu'ils
vont rencontrer 20 ou 30 personnes et
pas davantage on assiste un vote par
anticipation qui est estimé aux deux
tiers démocrate
merci philippe gelie je crois vincent
que nous avons adrien jaulmes
correspondant du figaro à washington en
direct j'en profite pour dire que
normalement
apparemment on va
voilerait à voir en tout cas il étonne
il est annoncé que by john joe biden
devrait s'exprimer incessamment sous peu
5h30 gmt ce qui fait si mes calculs sont
bons à 6 heures 30 heure de paris donc
glissante airs de père de wilmington
alors nommé le jeune choeur quartier
général dans le delaware et ben
justement on va vite faut filer à
washington retrouver votre successeur
adrien jaulmes ce bonjour adrien bonsoir
bonsoir pour vous effectivement parce
qu'il est encore tard et on vous fait
veiller tard adrien qu'elle est
actuellement l'atmosphère déjà à
washington on parlait de rue qui était
barricadé notamment autour de la maison
blanche les barricades se sont dressés
par tous dans des derniers jours donc
tout le monde s'attendait ou du mois se
préparer à d'éventuels troubles heures
en
il faut se rendre compte que c'est une
élection qui est qui et or complètement
hors norme notamment en raison des
enjeux en raison du contexte
avec la crise sanitaire et la crise
économique dans laquelle elle se déroule
donc ça c'était le côté social qu'elle
restait rouler mais mais en revanche la
ville n'était pas il n'y avait pas une
effervescence particulière à part
quelques quelques rues autour de la
maison blanche
c'était surtout tout le monde
s'attendait et et surtout rivés à ses
écrans de télévision en regardant les
premiers résultats de ce scrutin
vous avez suivi donc les résultats toute
la nuit qu'est ce que vous retenez
qu'est ce qui vous frappe
outre bien sûr que le l'écart est plus
plus serré que ce conte ce qu'on
attendait moi je crois que ce qui est ce
qui est évident c'est la façon
extraordinaire dont donald trump a avec
laquelle donald trump a résisté enfin
compte tenu du contexte de sassou le
contexte économique c'est à dire une
récession qui est d'ampleur quasiment
historique d'une crise d'une crise
sanitaire laquelle donald trump n'a pas
exactement même si on a un peu exagéré
la la le degré de le degré de désordre
avec lequel il a il a réagi à cette
crise tous ces facteurs auraient dû
quand même peser de façon importante sur
les sur les résultats électoraux dans un
dans un cadre normal on a une deuxième
fois après quatre ans après son élection
donald trump a montré qu'il n'avait pas
été élu accidentellement en 2016 et
qu'il représentait pour des beaucoup de
raisons une vague profonde qui est
continuelle incarnez donc il y avait les
électeurs qui ont continué à voter pour
donald trump ont voulu insister en
disant on n'a pas voté par hasard pour
ce personnage là le système qu'on a
dénoncé en 2016 donc continuer à ne pas
nous convenir et joe biden même s'il ne
même s'il n'est pas comme hillary
clinton même s'il n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes travers eh bien on continue à
considérer qu'il revenait quelque chose
dont on ne veut pas je pense que c'est
ça l'enseignement et encore une fois le
comme le comme le disait comme le disait
les présidents précédents intervenants
et notamment philippe gelie le on
assiste à 50 élections simultanées dans
50 états américains et il est beaucoup
trop tôt encore pour donner le donner le
résultat
il ya quand même ce phénomène singulier
qui est le fait que donald trump a
résisté
envers et contre tout et reste un et
reste un formidable adversaires y
compris dans des conditions qui auraient
suffi à balayer n'importe quel autre
politicien classique
alors justement donald trump qu'est ce
qu'il est on sait que joe biden doit
parler incessamment sous peu et qu'est
ce qu'il est en train de faire pour
l'instant
bah en fait tout le monde avait annoncé
dans la halle trump se préparant un coup
d'état
plus ou moins légales se préparant à
annoncé sa victoire dès les premiers
résultats y ait en fait il reste
étonnamment silencieux il a plutôt été
en retrait ou du moins on a pas on n'a
pas assisté à des déclarations des
sorties tonitruantes d'un personnage qui
pourtant pas qui a donné qui est
pourtant donné plutôt généralement
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui est plutôt
portée sur l'action que sur la réflexion
ou du moins qui à bout de tendance avec
s'exprimer que plutôt qu'à rester en
retrait mais pourtant c'est ce qui c'est
ce qui s'est produit
alors ce soir la maison blanche était
entouré par quelques part quelques
centaines d'activistes
ou de goût de badauds de manifestants et
qui est qui était devant les grilles de
la deûle à qui entoure la maison blanche
il y avait aussi deux réceptions qui
avait lieu au trump hôtel qui est
l'hôtel qui sauvent non loin et qui est
de la propriété donald trump
mais il n'y avait pas grand chose qui ce
qui se produisait jusqu'à présent il y a
eu un autre scrutin comme toujours aux
états unis
il y en a plein d'autres mais il ya un
autre enjeu le sénat la chambre des
représentants est-ce qu'on a des
estimations à l'heure actuelle adrien
elles sont encore complète mais là aussi
les les signaux qui sont qui sont
intéressants c'est le fait que mitch
mcconnell qui est le qui est le chef de
la majorité républicaine au sénat qui
est le tien en fait cette chambre haute
qui est un organe clé dans les
institutions américaines mais aussi que
lindsey graham qui était le qui était
notre figure de ce sénat républicains
ont été réélus chacun dans l'or dans
leurs états respectifs montre aussi que
cette espèce de cette vague bleue
qu'annonçaient certains commentateurs ou
deux mois qu'ils espéraient beaucoup de
démocrates sept votes sanction que selon
lequel les électeurs auraient dû aurait
dieu de renvoyer ses électeurs à donner
une majorité démocrate au sénat
ça risque de pas se produire donc encore
une fois on à votre très serré qui
indiquent d'abord que l'amérique est
très divisée sans le sait tous mais
aussi que y compris malgré une gestion
qui est qui a été quand même largement
problématique 6 mai calamiteux savez pas
quel point de vue on se place
et bien en fait les électeurs
considèrent que c'est pas ça le plus
important que dans le trou frappe les
républicains ne sont pas responsables de
la pandémie et que leur façon dont ils
ont géré finalement dépeint si
catastrophique que ça et et qu'en fait
là aussi les raisons pour lesquelles on
vote pour eux et bien là il demeure
rendez vous vous parliez à l'instant de
la personnalité de donald trump et et du
fait que des des électeurs qui avaient
voté pour lui en 2016 ont reconduit leur
vote cette année malgré les scandales
effectivement on a l'impression que les
scandales de lys sur trump comme sur du
téflon avait dit quelqu'un sur les
réseaux sociaux
tous les scandales même les derniers
glisse sur lui c'est incompréhensible
pour ceux qui ne sont pas adhérents à
donald trump comment vous l'expliquez
comment on peut expliquer cette adhésion
malgré les faits malgré les scandales ou
en fait je pense qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être un d'être un adepte
inconditionnel d'un autre homme pour
comprendre qu'il ya un mélange assez
curieux et c'est inhabituel c'est un
homme politique elle c'est un mélange de
cynisme et de candeur dire que donald
ray et on entend cela j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup d'électeurs républicains et
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui vous
disent on sait à peu près qu'il est on
est pas quelqu un de très recommandable
oh mais au moins il est rien cacher et
il faut reconnaître à dire le fait de
suivre le compte le compte twitter de
donald trump donne un accès quasiment
direct à ce qu'ils pensent ces réactions
épidermiques parfois irrationnelle c'est
ses foucades c est effectivement il ya
un certain nombre d'électeurs qui
considère que qui préfère ça à dd des
personnalités politiques plus policé qui
ont être discours plus cadré et qui ne
disent pas exactement ce qu'il pense
d'accès se dit pas parce qu'on fait
quand on est un homme politique on doit
ménager la chèvre et le chou ben va
donner le troc vidéo près ce qu'il pense
et en fait ça plaît alors ça a sans
doute ça un écho particulier dans le
dans un univers mental américain ouvrant
soeur ou le leu leu ce qu on appelle ça
en anglais le strict aux kings c'est à
dire la façon pas les raisons de parler
de direct le franc parler est une
qualité qui qui est plus importante que
la compétence que l'intellectualisme
pour une certaine à ce qu'un certain
qu'un respect des formes donc je pense
que donald trump continuer à bénéficier
là dessus et et certaines de ses sorties
pendant ces rassemblements électoraux
quand il dit quand il annonce aux
s'adresse aux femmes des hauts femmes
des banlieues il leur dit écoutez je
vous mets
j'ai pas beaucoup de temps à vous
consacrer mais s'il vous plaît si
j'avais le temps je le ferai mais vous
vous avez compris je suis très occupé
donc faites le donc une partie des
médias américains poussent des hauts
cris on crie au scandale mais en fait
finalement c'est assez honnête tout le
monde sait très bien que c'est un homme
politique qu'il est là pour gagner
l'élection et qu'il a pas beaucoup de
temps à consacrer à 17 électeurs
potentiels
voilà il ya un effet donald trump qui
n'est pas en gros tous les électeurs ne
sont pas forcément des gens stupides ou
des racistes ou ou des who des membres
d'organisations des organisations
extrémistes 625 sur figaro live dans 5
minutes maintenant on annonce en tous
les cas une prise de parole de joe biden
une petite question encore une dernière
adria à l'instant on voit que ya des
recomptages qui sont annoncés en
pennsylvanie en tous les cas que on ne
devrait pas connaître les décomptes
avant au moins ce soir heures heure
locale donc ça va faire dans la nuit
peut-être demain matin pour nous dans
dans cet état clé dans cet état
stratégique
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on s'apprête à
l'heure actuelle dans en tout cas dans
ce qu'on dit sur les médias américains
sur les grandes sur un grand network
américain à un grand recomptage
alors on a plus adrian on va peut-être
leur trouvez vous philippe déjà je vous
voyais sourire quand adrien parlait de
cynisme et le mélange de cynisme et de
candeur chez jean a fait ça j'adhère
complètement à l'analyse de rien
il a raison sur toute la ligne il a
raison sur le fait que ce en juger
quelle que soit l'issue et est le
vainqueur final de la course
ça n'est pas clairement votre sanction
comme certains l'avaient anticipée à
cause du coc vide à cause du fait que
trump n'a pas payé d'impôt depuis depuis
dix ans et c'est la question que vous
avez posé sur les scandales on peut
constater aussi que joe biden avait sept
c'est cette affaire avec son fils qui
aurait profité de la venue affaires de
corruption oui dont il est accusé en
2002 suspicions de corruption pour ce de
son fils qui aurait profité du fait que
son père était vice président pour
obtenir un job dans une entreprise
ukrainienne mais en fait ça n'a pas
compté neuf non plus c'est à dire que
trump a transmis son immunité au
scandale à baden en gros on a voté pour
train pour ou contre trap est ce qui
ressort de deux
du vote et du dépouillement à l'heure
actuelle c'est qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de gens qui sont pour trump et que
largement peut-être plus même que contre
un peu comme l'a dit adrien ses manières
finalement plaisent
le fait qu'ils ne se comporte pas comme
un politicien classique et pour
l'instant il tient la rampe
c est ce sentiment en titre oms et s
était l'atout maître de joe biden c'est
là dessus qu'il ya aussi miser sa
campagne donc c est ce qu on peut
considérer que c'est l'action qu'il a
misé sa non campagne c'est-à-dire que il
a un petit des internautes
il a il a laissé le terrain en gros il
l'a déserté le champ de bataille il a
fait quelques vidéos masqué depuis son
basement le sous sol de sa maison
il a fait très très peu de deux réunions
électorales en présentiel comme on dit
aujourd'hui
et encore c'était des gens dans leurs
voitures qui klaxonnaient au lieu
d'applaudir et c'est alors que trump a
battu la campagne avec une énergie quand
même assez incroyable puisque les
derniers jours il enchaîné plus de cinq
rassemblements électoraux par jour avec
des discours d'une heure à chaque fois
donc clairement il a surmonté le coc
vide qui est dont il a été atteint dans
les dernières semaines de la campagne ça
compte aussi
je pense que les électeurs regardent
quel est le des deux candidats celui qui
a le plus d'appétit et six trains plan
porte cette année de nouveau il aura
commis la même erreur qu hillary clinton
en 2016 qui croyait alors elle s'était
c'était plus par arrogance les moins par
calcul tout ce qu'elle croyait que
certains états était hors de portée en
particulier dans le midwest on a vu la
carte était hors de portée d'un
un républicain et donc elle n'y avait
plus fait campagne et trump au contraire
aller porter le fer en territoire ennemi
si l'on veut aujourd'hui il est ils
essayent de défendre ses états qu'ils
avaient enduré 2016
mais joe biden a pris à faire un choix
tactique de considérer qu' il ne
pourrait rien faire qui suscite autant
d' enthousiasme en sa faveur que
l'énergie négative générée par trump
chez ses propres supporteurs je sais pas
si je suis clair et en gros il a misé
sur le sentiment de rejet de trump qui
était censé unir une assez large
coalition du centre il ya même certains
républicains
les clients qui ont pris possession de
la première league mais à modéré oui ou
même
enfin les neversois si vous voulez les
les républicains
orthodoxes qui n'aiment pas
l'hétérodoxie de trump et ses manières
et qui ont clairement pris position
beaucoup de généraux beaucoup de monde
du 2 d'experts de la sécurité nationale
ont pris publiquement position pro
travail puis ça va jusqu'à l'ère
d'autres extrêmes c'est-à-dire les
supporteurs de bernie sanders a haussé
au cas joe cortez
l'élu du bronx etc réélu réélu sans
problème d'elle oui bien sûr dans sa
circonscription c'est le contraire
serait quand même assez surprenant
vous parliez philippe gelie de 2,2 du
candidat qui donne envie le plus et vous
citiez donald trump par rapport à joe
biden est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer
également que au delà de celui qui donne
envie c'est celui qui donne l'impression
d'être le plus fort physiquement on a vu
le côté phoenix de donald trump
on a reproché à joe biden une certaine
moi je crois que joe biden atteint son
âge son âge est ce que son âge à jouer
ils ont tous les deux bons jobs hayden a
l'air un peu plus fatigué que donald
trump c'est clair il ya 77 ans il aura
bientôt soixante dix huit ans ça ce
serait le plus vieux président à entrer
à la maison blanche de l'histoire
donald travail 74 ans il est très
énergique on l'a vu dans la campagne ce
qui se passe c'est que le pari de byden
de s'appuyer sur sur une énergie
négative sur un vote de rejet de train
c'est quelque chose sans précédent côté
démocrate
l'adage de la politique américaine c'est
durable caroline line and democrats fall
in love c'est à dire qu'il ya une
discipline de vote chez les républicains
classiquement qui est une fois que le
chef de file a été choisi les
républicains purs et durs votent pour
lui
chez les démocrates l'histoire a montré
qu'il fallait un enthousiasme une
énergie et tous les démocrates qui ont
été élues depuis un demi siècle étaient
des visages nouveaux
relativement jeune et relativement
modérée carter clinton obama pas des
septuagénaires
qui sont dans la politique depuis l'âge
de 29 ans et qui compte uniquement sur
le rejet de l'adversaire donc le pari de
donald de joe biden était quand même
très haut très osée en même temps
compréhensible compte tenu de la
situation de la crise économique du coc
vide etc
mais c'est peut-être une mauvaise
lecture politique du pays que d'avoir
cru que le rejet de donald trump
suffirait à faire élire
joe biden et on le sera espérons le dans
les heures qui viennent et pour
l'instant joe biden reste en tous les
cas en avance 1 selon les les bulls
légal mais ça va être serré
est ce qu'on peut dire uniquement à
cette heure ci c'est que la grande vague
bleue que certains prédisaient n'a pas
lieu
il ya peut-être eu un blue mirage on
verra ça peut-être dire à votre
éditorial avant la demi-heure ag boula
chiffre juste or c'était parce que je
l'avais suivi et je voulais savoir si
vous prépariez à ça dans votre dans un
de vos prochains éditoriaux qu'on va
avoir le plaisir de lire avant là tout
préparé avant 2 avant de vous le seui un
professionnalisme très anglo-saxon
peut-être une question qui est posée par
nos internautes
d'abord on a répondu à la question
pourquoi est ce que bill downe a fait
aussi peu mythique s'avoue lui avait
répondu est ce que est ce qu'on c est ce
qu on a une idée en tous les cas sur le
sur la participation est ce que la
grande participation qu'on a observé en
particulier avant le vote sur le
phénomène du vote du orly vote y est ce
qu'on sait pour l'instant à qui ça
profite à mon avis à l'arrivée ça va
profiter aux sondeurs qui vont y trouver
une excuse pour s'être trompé
s'ils se sont trompés parce que
effectivement il ya des réservoirs de
vote des lecteurs
nouveau donc difficiles à anticiper
et l'une des grandes inconnues c'est ces
nouveaux électeurs et est il plutôt
républicain plutôt démocrates pro trump
etc
il ya eu beaucoup de spéculations
pendant la campagne sur l'existence de
ce qu'on appelle les électeurs de trains
timide ceux qui n'osent pas dire ça
paraît un peu surprenant après quatre
ans de pouvoir de donald trump à la
maison blanche et même certains
analystes ont dit mais non celle inverse
aujourd'hui c'est dans les zones rurales
ou trump domine largement le paysage
politique qu'il y a des électeurs
démocrates timide qui n'ose pas mettre
une pancarte biden dans la pelouse sur
leur pelouse et donc il y avait cet
inconnu mais à l'arrivée c'est trop tôt
pour dire peut-être que les deux vont
s'équilibrer peut-être qu'il ya eu
autant de nouveaux électeurs
républicains que de nouveaux des
électeurs démocrates là honnêtement on
est encore au milieu du gué en tous les
cas il y à une attente nerveuse ce que
nous disent les dépêches des agences en
ce moment à wilmington qui est là où
doit s'exprimer
joe biden sur un parking il paraît qu'il
y à déjà des voitures qui l'attendait
qui se sont déjà qu'ils sont déjà partis
donc c'est le candidat démocrate doit
s'exprimer dans les minutes à venir on
va libérer
philippe gelie une peut-être tout
peut-être peut-être une toute dernière
question je vais y arriver de cet
internaute qui dit d'un côté on a des
records de participation de l'autre un
risque que l'élection ait devant les
tribunaux devant les tribunaux est ce un
bon signe pour la démocratie question à
l'éditorialiste que vous êtes
formulée comme ça ce ne serait pas un
très bon signe pour la démocratie si
l'élection présidentielle américaine
devait être arbitré infiné par les
tribunaux comme en 2000 elle avait été
arbitré par la cour suprême pour que
cette condition soit remplie il faut que
tous dépendance à l'état ou de 2 et que
dans cet état là comme en floride en
l'écart entre les deux candidats soient
de 570 voix
il peut y avoir des contestations il y
en a toutes tous toujours et il y en
aura il y en a tout le temps il ya des
armées d'avocats d2 que des deux
représentants les deux camps dans tous
les états et il y aura des contestations
ici ou là sur le dépouillement sur la
qualification des votes et c'est la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
est-ce que ces contestations seront
décisives dans la définition du résultat
final et ça c'est beaucoup plus rare
donc il est fréquent qu'il y ait des
contestations il est parfaitement normal
qu'elle soit portée devant la justice
les juges les tribunaux sont ouverts aux
états unis les procureurs tienne bureaux
ouverts pendant la journée électorale et
la soirée électorale
on doit pouvoir contester les résultats
ça n'est pas le fait de ce n'est pas le
fait que tu rames soient mauvais joueur
ou que non al gore a aussi contesté les
résultats en 2000 et il avait raison le
faire quand c'est très serré quand il ya
un doute on conteste les résultats mais
il est rare que ce soit absolument
décisif
voilà c'est ce qu'on avait vu en 2000
peut-être que c'est ce qu'on verra cette
année merci beaucoup
philippe merci d'avoir un philippin
d'avoir fait cette première partie de la
matinale et vous de la dernière partie
de la nuit avec nous on va si on va vous
lire dans le
la nouvelle version en tous les cas du
figaro patrick st paul va vous remplacer
on va peut-être aller à pékin retrouver
sébastien falletti absolument rendez
vous tout de suite à pékin en chine avec
notre correspondant du figaro sébastien
falletti bonjour sébastien bonjour
bonjour avec nous pour cette matinale
spéciale la élections américaines alors
pékin at-elle une préférence sur le
choix du vainqueur
alors vous savez la chine a l'habitude
de toujours de selon le principe de
non-ingérence dans les affaires d'autres
pays de rester très prudente
donc cette fois ci elle n'a comme
toulouse m elle n'a pas du tout indiqué
de préférence il ya un débat au sommet
dirigeants disons que le le régime
chinois est résigné il estime que de
toute façon quel que soit le vainqueur
de cette élection
il s'attend à une administration dur
vous savez que donald trump a été
extrêmement imprévisible et et les rues
de ces dernières années avec la chine
qu'il a même désigné comme un ennemi
régulièrement durant sa campagne
mais côté démocrates désormais on
affiche aussi une ligne très durs contre
pékin et donc à pékin
on se prépare de toute façon à des
années difficiles
maintenant sur le plan tactique il ya
des différences entre les deux candidats
et beaucoup pensent que les dirigeants
chinois s préférerait sans doute le
retour des démocrates car ça offrirait
sans doute un répit au régime et surtout
plus de visibilité plus de lisibilité
sur les actions washington vous savez
que le régime chinois aiment parfois
infliger des surprises mais il déteste
en subir et c'est vrai que donald trump
n'a pas été avare de deux gestes
imprévisible depuis surtout depuis deux
2 2 ans depuis le déclenchement de la
guerre commerciale en 2018
il assène des coups de butoir contre la
deuxième puissance mondiale
sur le plan économique technologique
mais aussi
en renforçant ses positions militaires
dans la zone pacifique
en soutenant taiwan donc beaucoup
d'éléments d'un kiki qui en rendent
particulièrement anxieux la chine de gym
ping et bien sûr il y à l'espoir qu'au
moins avec une victoire de baden il y
aurait toujours de de l'antagonisme du
bras de fer stratégique mais au moins on
pourrait un peu mieux le comprendre ce
qui va arriver dans les prochains mois
les prochaines années et peut-être
gagner du temps aussi parce que la chine
malgré sa réussite face au co ville
malgré une économie qui repart reste
dans un contexte très incertain sur le
plan de la croissance mais aussi sur le
plan géostratégique est apparu assez
isolé c'est à des mois face à de
nombreuses autres puissances et donc il
y as pour la chine l'idée que les années
à venir sont des années difficiles sont
des années où il faut continuer à se
renforcer sur le plan intérieur sur le
plan technologique pour être plus
indépendant économiquement et que donc
gagner du temps peut-être la bonne la
bonne séquence pour pour pour la chine
et l'espoir c'est peut-être que avec une
administration démocrate
au moins on pourra parler on pourra lire
ce qui va se passer dans les prochaines
années
sébastien falletti si on vous suit ça
veut dire que dans le cas d'une
une élection de joe biden à la tête des
états unis il poursuivrait on va dire le
bras de fer commercial avec la chine
mais avec une méthode on va dire plus
douce que celle de donald trump
non alors c'est là la question la grande
question c'est que il y à un débat à
pékin et certains affirment que la chine
au contraire aurait intérêt à un
deuxième mandat donald trump pourquoi
parce que évidemment baden offrent de la
visibilité mais il va apporter
il va continuer à être très dur sur la
chine et surtout il risque de renouer le
lien avec les alliés des etats-unis en
europe mais aussi en asie
particulièrement les pays d'asie asie du
sud-est où les pays riverains comme la
corée du sud le japon on peut apprécier
les les latitudes donald trump
l'amérique d'abord et elles se sentent
souvent abandonnés donc le retour des
démocrates signifie aussi le risque
d'une alliance d'encerclement contre la
chine donc si vous voulez pour payer
aujourd'hui il ya un vrai débat
il ya un débat interne sur qui serait le
moins mauvais président pour la chine
dans les deux cas ça sera dur et voilà
certains pensent que abel un répit à
court terme mais que à long terme c'est
peut-être plus dur pour la chine parce
que il y à risque d'encerclement avec
trump on s'attend à des coups de boutoir
répétés très incertain mais aussi en
même temps sur le plan stratégique à
long terme
il détruit le réseau d'alliances
occidentale et ça à long terme c'est bon
pour la chine pour la chine renaissante
où il ya ce dilemme ici et à la fin la
chine le régime est un régime
pragmatique le régime marxiste léniniste
il fera avec ce qu'il a devant lui et de
toute façon il ne fera pas de concession
majeure parce que il a son nom plan la
semaine dernière le parti communiste
s'est retrouvé en conclave à pékin et
ils ont dévoilé un plan très précis
jusqu'en 2035
donc comme toujours le régime c'est sa
force se projette dans la durée et il se
concentre d'abord sur son agenda et il
se prépare donc à
à des années difficiles face à
washington
si vous avez été vous étiez en direct
depuis pékin où vous êtes correspondant
pour pour le figaro nous allons tout de
suite retrouvé joe biden qui s'apprête à
délivrer un discours en direct depuis le
delaware
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
novelli constatent en termes de devoir
beaucoup de gens se sont déplacés
jusqu'aux urnes mais comme je les ai
toujours dit ce n'est pas moi ou à
donald trump de dire qui a remporté
l'élection
c'est la décision une décision qui
revient au peuple américain mais je suis
optimiste
l'issue de cette élection je tiens à
tous vous remercier tous autant que vous
êtes qui est allé voter est d'ailleurs
merci aux démocrates qui ont organisé la
campagne ici dans le delaware et john le
gouverneur mais oui oui même sur des
routes toute l'équipe
un travail extraordinaire vous avez fait
un extraordinaire travail vous tous les
bénévoles tous ceux qui ont participé à
ce processus démographe démocratique
je remercie tous mes soutiens dans cet
état est partout aux états-unis merci
merci merci et vous m'avez déjà entendu
dire que à ce qu'on a dans
ville de mon grand père à chaque fois
que je passe gens me disent garde la foi
garde la foi et bien justement c'est ce
que je vous dis on garde la foi on a la
foi et merci merci merci j'adore cet
endroit
[Musique]
voilà courte allocution donc de joe
biden depuis son fief dans le delaware
patrick saint paul chef du service
international ancien correspondant à
pékin notamment est entre autre à berlin
à tel aviv nous a rejoint donc joe biden
confiant plutôt combatif à l'instant une
courte allocution le suspense est à cet
instant total oui bien sûr joe biden
la course n'est pas terminée ce sera une
course au finish ils parlaient d'eux
la ville de son grand-père donc de la
pennsylvanie il reste optimiste pour la
pennsylvanie où
d'après les
les résultats qui sont en train de
tomber il n'ya rien n'est joué
totalement puisque le décompte notamment
des votes par correspondance qui est
plutôt favorable démocrates en général
n'a été interrompue ou n'a pas commencé
et donc le décompte en pennsylvanie va
se prolonger dans la journée de mercredi
et probablement on n'aura pas de
résultat dans cet état là aujourd'hui
pour nous
peut-être demain ou après demain
aux etats unis rien n'est joué encore
dans cet état et il est encore il a
encore ses chances malgré l'énorme
surprise créée par donald trump réaction
d'ailleurs à l'instant de donald trump
qui nous dit nous alors il le dit en
anglais ou en europe
big men the rain tous styles sélection
donc nous sommes nous sommes au
grandement au mais ils sont en train de
voler cette élection donc trump réagi
aussitôt
la prise de parole de bayonne est ce que
d'ailleurs c'est pas à contre emploi on
a l'impression de bayonne nous a fait du
trump là non parce qu'on est en train
d'entrer comme on voit que c'est une
élection chaque vote va compter ça veut
dire qu'on va rentrer dans
une période où on va les contestations
possibles vont s'ouvrir et on va
contester tous les tous les bulletins
dans l'est dans les endroits où
l'élection sera la plus serrée tout sera
contestée et donc on est en train
d'entrer dans une bataille psychologique
et c'est ça qui est en train de se
passer entre by donald trump
c'est que c'est qu'ils posent leurs
jalons pour cette bataille qui va
s'engager et l'enjeu aussi maintenant
qu'on rentre dans une bataille qui
risque de devenir aussi juridique aux
gouttes de tous et de tous et des
comptes qui vont prendre plus de temps
c'est que ça se mette que voilà que les
supporters des uns et des autres
commencent à se mobiliser autrement
qu'en allant voter c'est à dire en
créant des troubles dans la rue c'est ça
le danger aujourd'hui qui tout ce ce
pourquoi on avait mis en garde ces
derniers jours et ces dernières semaines
avec avec les émeutes qui ont eu lieu
notamment cet été
voilà c'est un danger qui devient plus
plus présent
avec avec cette élection serrée et
maintenant nous ne les laisserons pas
faire c'est ce que vient de déclarer à
l'instant donald trump
donc effectivement la bataille va quand
ils ont dit que ça fait des mois que les
avocats des deux camps en tout cas
étudie tous les recours possibles et qu'
il y à cette option qui est sur la table
de faire une bataille menée maintenant
une bataille juridique
bien sûr ça se joue dans les dents les
états pivots ça se joue comté par comté
parce qu'il ya aussi des comptes et
pivot dans les états pivots et là c'est
une bataille d'avocats qui se joue au
budo bout de l'élection est au bout du
comptage des votes et d'un éventuel
recomptage comme ans comme on a vu en
floride
en 2000 dans la bataille gore bush
donald trump doit faire une intervention
il a annoncé d'ailleurs sur sur twitter
à will be making state man tonight big
wind point d'exclamation donc on attend
son intervention patrick saint paul
avant de passer la parole à renault qui
va nous faire un dernier point info avec
les dernières derniers résultats et les
dernières estimations
je voulais savoir et probablement
beaucoup d'internautes aussi s'interroge
sur ce qu'on a dit du vote par
anticipation et la participation des
jeunes en particulier dont on a dit
qu'ils étaient massivement nombreux à
s'être rendus et avoir voté à 7 à ce
scrutin
est-ce que c'est par eux que
joe biden finalement pourrait remporter
la mise ou au contraire finalement cette
massive participation dont il était
question elle n'est pas aussi massives
que ça si la participation est massive
après il ya les jeunes
on verra au bout du décompte pour pau
pour qui et pour quel candidat ils ont
ils ont voté il ya aussi les mis en
minorité
c'est la grande surprise c'est aussi que
les minorités votre beaucoup plus trump
que ce qui était prévu et donc c'est
comme en floride notamment en floride et
donc ça a fait basculer en fait les
toutous toutes les prévisions et les
sondeurs se
ont du mal à comprendre cette amérique
même des américains comprennent pas ce
pays et c'est ça qui est très étonnant
c'est que la vague bleue qui avait été
annoncée par tous les sondeurs n'a pas
eu lieu
et quand trump parle d'un big green
qu'il remporte élections ou pas il a
quand même créé la surprise ça ça en soi
c'est déjà une victoire parce que tout
le monde avait annoncé sa défaite
les sondeurs les médias et
l'establishment ou une énorme vague
bleue et là on voit que cette vague
bleue n'a pas eu lieu vous disiez
patrick saint paul que il est difficile
de comprendre les votes de certains
électeurs américains à l'endroit de
donald trump en particulier est
essentiellement par les minorités qui
parmi elles sont nombreuses à et en
particulier les minorités d'origine
hispanique qui ont voté je crois pour un
quart au moins pour donald trump
on peut avoir un peu de mal à comprendre
vu d'ici que des minorités qui sont
souvent pointées du doigt maltraités
dans les discours d'un candidat comme
donald trump puisse aller s'engager pour
lui est ce que est ce qu'on peut avoir
une explication à donner par rapport à 7
à cette situation la wii une explication
c'est là on voit sur les latinos quand
c'est un car c'est à dire que ça dépasse
le prennent des cubains
traditionnellement les qui les cubains
vote républicain à cause du problème de
mieux régime castriste là on voit que
c'est pas uniquement les cubains il ya
une chose c'est que en fait quand on
écoute un peu par des ces minorités que
ce soit les afro américains où les
hispaniques 10 mais de toute façon les
deux candidats où chaque tous les
candidats tous tous les présidents sont
un peu un peu raciste c'est dans leur
état d'esprit il ya ceux enfin chez
certains d'entre eux il ya cette idée là
donc disent finalement trump hayden
quelle différence
et puis il ya ce côté aussi chez les
hispaniques ou le côté un peu macho qui
casse les codes de trump c'est quelque
chose qui peut séduire une partie de sa
personnalité
ultra viril on va dire ou qui affiche en
tout cas les attributs d'une certaine
virilité qui peuplèrent effectivement du
mal ballon rond ça plaît à certains
d'entre eux rient à l'instant plusieurs
plusieurs résultats qui tombent on va on
va prendre renommée déjà happé donc
association sa société de presse donc
dit que la floride est remporté par
donald trump
en revanche en revanche fox news pas
favorable joe biden dit que le minnesota
seraient gagnés par joe biden et ça
c'était un c'est un état c'est un état
pivot bon qui avait été remportée déjà
par hillary clinton
à la dernière élection mais ça prouve
que quand on est toujours dans cette
dans ce contexte de résultats très très
serré oui c'est très serré alors que de
perdre minier sata sa paillasse pen men
men une bonne nouvelle pour pour bill
dann pour vois là mais de plus en plus
on se dirige vers le scénario où ça va
ce l'élection va se jouer dans une
poignée d'états et
et on risque de ne pas connaître le
résultat
aujourd'hui puisque ça ça peut se jouer
en pennsylvanie c'est ce que c'est ce
que dit d'ailleurs joe biden c'est à
dire qu'il lit on ne prévoit pas de
connaître les résultats jusqu'à mercredi
matin donc c'est à dire cet après midi
pendant les états unis pour nous pour
nous et peut-être plus tard
donc on se place plutôt dans une
configuration qui rappellerait celle de
l'an 2000 alors l'an 2000 ça avait duré
plusieurs semaines la en pennsylvanie on
a jusqu'à vendredi pour compter les
votes par que les bulletins de vote par
correspondance
donc voilà oui ça peut durer jusqu'à
plusieurs jours et ensuite une fois le
résultat connu il y a le problème des
recours juridiques qui peuvent aussi
prolonger la tente
d'un résultat puisque tant que tant
qu'il ya des recours le résultat n'est
pas définitif patrick saint paul à
propos de recours juridiques il ya
claudius 15 sur lefigaro.fr qui
s'interrogent les etats-unis vont-ils
suivre l'exemple des contestations de
résultats comme en afrique ou dans les
pays de l'est
alors où ils n'ont pas entendu ils n'ont
pas attendu l afrique et les pays de
l'est puisque en 2000 ça c'est déjà joué
par des contestations en floride après
ça se joue état par état
ça dépend aussi de l'attitude in fine et
du gouverneur de l'état
on se souvient que le en floride
c'était le frère de george w bush qui
était gouverneur à l'époque jeff bush et
qui in fine est avait mis fin à tous et
recomptages interminable des bulletins
de vote perforé c'est lui qui avait
avait mis un stop
tout ça est ce qu'elle est joué en
faveur de son frère in fine et il ya
peut-être un côté un peu africains là
dedans peut-être une autre une autre
question trump de l'internaute sur fear
alive trump a adopté un style médiatique
comme reagan avant lui face à des
démocrates très sage trop sage trop sage
ou prudent c'est à dire que cette
élection n'était pas une élection
normale
on a eu cette crise du coc vide
ces deux stratégies différentes dire que
biden a joué voilà que la carte des
scientifiques des deux ce qui respecte
l'avis des médecins
donc port du masque de meetings en
distance yale ou sur des parkings à
l'extérieur et c'est vrai que ça donne
un côté qui est pas très chaleureux qui
est un peu désincarnées alors que trump
lui n'a pas porté le masque
il a vaincu le vide il a fait preuve
d'une énergie débordante et mais voilà
ces meetings y avait des foules qui
étaient là pour pour l'acclamer c'était
une atmosphère très différente et c'est
vrai que ça donne une image
peut-être plus proche des électeurs il
n'y avait pas de masque tout à l'heure
patrick saint paul on va passer la main
tenant de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
et retrouver washington avec cette
fois-ci pierre-yves dugua correspondant
économique pour le figaro depuis 1995
qui est basé à washington qui arrive du
gabon jours
alors moi je ne vous entends pas vous
m'entendez je vous entends très bien moi
aussi
pierre-yves fin octobre on annoncé que
les états unis sortent est
officiellement de la récession avec une
croissance de 33 1% du pib au troisième
trimestre et pourtant on entend dire que
les états unis ne vont pas bien et sont
en crise elle va comment l'économie
américaine
l'économie américaine va beaucoup moins
mal que ce que l'on craignait au mois
d'avril elle n'a pas rattrapé tout le
terrain qu'elle abandonnait de manière
dramatique
au second trimestre le secteur
manufacturier a rebondi beaucoup plus
nettement que le secteur des services
seulement voilà le secteur des services
et les deux tiers de l'économie
américaine le secteur manufacturier
s'est à peine 12% donc l'école b
américaine va mieux
toutefois tout ce qui s'est produit
depuis trois ou quatre mois ne veut pas
dire grand chose par ce qui compte
maintenant c'est ce qui va se produire
au cours des prochaines semaines avec ce
risque manifeste de confinement même si
ça pouvait être un recond finement
ciblée aux états unis on risque
d'observer aux états unis ce qui se
passe en europe et qui à ce moment-là
ralentirait considérablement la
croissance américaine et même menacerait
de rechute en récession
dans cette pandémie et ses conséquences
sur sur l'économie du pays
est ce qu'on pouvait dire au printemps
dernier que l'économie des etats unis se
portait mieux aujourd'hui qu'elle ne se
portaient à la fin du mandat de barack
obama en 2017
ah oui indiscutablement les records
ont été battus par l'économie américaine
soudain empreinte jusqu'au mois de
janvier février
en termes d'emploi on était dans une
situation de quasi plein emploi est
clairement de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
dans de très nombreux secteurs pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui se traduisait par
une augmentation des salaires et en
particulier une augmentation plus rapide
des salaires les plus bas
notamment au profit des minorités
américaines
du point de vue de l'emploi le bilan de
donald trump jusqu'au début de la
pandémie était spectaculaire dans
d'autres domaines il l'était moins
en particulier dans le domaine très
important du redressement de la balance
commerciale les efforts brutaux de
donald trump pour secouer la chine lui
imposer des droits de douane élevés dans
le but de changer la direction des
échanges commerciaux américains n'ont
pas encore porté leurs fruits et bien
sûr tout ce qui s'est passé avec la
pandémie et le bouleversement des
chaînes d'approvisionnement remet en
cause les petits gains qui avait été
réalisé du point de vue commercial
par ailleurs en termes budgétaires alors
là bien entendu c'était la catastrophe
car les dépenses publiques ont
considérablement augmenté aux états unis
mais surtout les recettes fiscales ont
diminué en raison des multiples
réductions d'impôts qui ont été
pratiquées
soudain on trempe et l'impact net sur le
budget a été un aggravation du déficit
budgétaire qui depuis s'est
considérablement creusé en raison de la
crise qui a explosé au mois de mars
pierre-yves du gard si on regarde devant
nous maintenant quel que soit le
résultat à choisir entre trump ou by
donne quelle politique économique
l'avenir sera la plus bénéfique pour le
pays compte tenu de sa situation
sanitaire et de sa situation économique
aujourd'hui je dirais que la crise est
là pendant la crise du coronavirus et la
pandémie remettent tout en question
on ne peut pas savoir ce qui va se
passer en matière de politique
économique aux états unis
tant qu'on n'aura pas maîtrisé
véritablement
cette endémie et si les états unis
retombent en récession en raison de
reconsidérer on ne pourra pas accuser le
prochain président américain qu'il
s'agisse des tubes hayden ou qu'il
s'agisse de donald trump
si joe biden est élu il va chercher à
adopter une politique différente mais
manifestement les premiers trimestres de
son mandat seront grandement accaparé
par la gestion de la crise du cornât
virus dans les deux cas qu'il s'agisse
de joe biden ou de donald trump les le
prochain président des états unis peut
compter sur une politique monétaire
ultra généreuse puisque la réserve
fédérale a promis de maintenir des taux
d'intérêt nuls et de poursuivre ses
rachats de créances publiques qui
reviennent en fait à faire marcher la
planche à billets non seulement au cours
de l'année prochaine mais même au delà
en 2022
puis arrive à l'instant une dépêche est
tombée
disons que pour l'instant les indices
américains remontent alors que trump
mène dans certains états et taclés état
pivot est ce qu'on peut dire que les
bourses américaines finalement votre
trump non on est tenté de le dire mais
ça n'est pas exact les les grands
indices boursiers américains ont gagné
en gros 50 7% depuis que dan trump été
et est élu c'est un bond considérable
qui s'explique par les fortes réductions
d'impôts et la bonne santé de l'économie
américaine jusqu'au mois de janvier donc
de ce point de vue là où on suit est
absolument ravie d'un emprunt jusqu au
moins deux jusqu au moins de février
si joe biden est élu ce qui était le
scénario dont wall street s'était
convaincu jusqu'à ce soir citant aussi
joe biden est élu et dispose d'une
majorité démocrate au sénat où entre 8
et très content également
ça peut paraître paradoxal mais cela
s'explique parce que maintenant wall
street est très impatient de voir
adopter un nouveau plan de relance
massif pour prévenir la rechute de
l'économie américaine
récession donc à court et à moyen terme
wall street s'accorderait tout à fait
d'une élection de joe biden sida
l'emprunt reste président les choses
sont plus compliquées parce que le
président trump a été assez discret sur
ses intentions en matière de politique
économique au cours du second temps on
de son éventuel second mandat
parce que pour la simple raison qu'il a
réalisé la plupart de ses objectifs en
termes d'exécution de la politique
économique réforme fiscale est mise en
place de mécanismes de défense et
commerciaux qui sont censés forcer la
chine à changer ses pratiques
commerciales
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous depuis washington je
rappelle vous êtes correspondant
économique pour le figaro depuis 1995
à très bientôt qui arrive surtout merci
beaucoup aux patrons merci beaucoup
thierry et merci patrick vous allez nous
quitter puisque ça continue également
pour le figaro qui qui met à jour ses
versions pdf en tous les cas que vous
pouvez trouver sur le site un peu être
un dernier mot vous quand même c'est pas
la première élection américaine que vous
observez qu'est ce qui vous frappe est
peut-être une réaction à cet internaute
qui dit les américains aiment les héros
et iq trump a joué sur cette posture
depuis quatre ans pendant sa campagne il
a réussi son storytelling
[Musique]
oui il a réussi comme le disait à rien
jaune tout à l'heure aussi à à se
présenter comme
de nouveaux comme le candidat
antisystème skiff plaît toujours aux
amis américains où on a l'impression que
tout est dictée par washington et quand
on vit dans le minnesota où en
pennsylvanie ça peut washington peut
sembler un peu loin de 2 des
préoccupations des électeurs et trump a
réussi ce tour de force de d'être le
président sortant d'avoir été quatre ans
à la maison blanche à être celui qui à
la fois dirigé le système est d'une
certaine façon le contester aussi en
permanence et et à être de nouveau le
candidat antisystème
et là on voit aussi dans le dernier
tweet qu'il errait qui là qu'il a posté
là où lui sont signalés par twitter
signalé par twitter on dit que c'était
un contenu qui est contesté et parce que
en fait qui compte est de nouveau le
système dans ce tweet il dit qu' on ne
peut pas que les bulletins de
ne peuvent pas être déposés après la
fermeture du scrutin donc en joue sur
sur un peu sur les mots sur pour ses
bulletins de vote par correspondance qui
sont comptés après la fermeture de
des bureaux de vote où le comptage peut
durer pendant plusieurs jours sauf que
c'est le système électoral américain est
en fait ils contestent le système
électoral américain
et pour lui on devait arrêter de compter
aujourd'hui déclaré le vainqueur
aujourd'hui et lui avait dit qu'il se
déclarer vainqueur
il ne le fait pas pour l'instant mais il
conteste le système quand même scénario
où il pourrait se dire vainqueur
aujourd'hui puis finalement dire plus
tard même si t'es pas reconnu vainqueur
finalement j'ai été vainqueur de johan
oui on voit qu'il le fait pas parce que
il dit aussi beaucoup de choses qui
n'est qui ne fait pas ina et connaît
quand même le danger vers ça mettrait un
peu le feu aux poudres dans les rues en
tout cas ce serait un très très grand
danger si ils avaient recours à cette
stratégie
merci beaucoup patrick merci beaucoup
patrick saint paul à on va retrouver
maintenant renault fier qui était en
direct dans une autre partie du studio
pour nous donner les dernières
estimations les derniers résultats état
par état et les dernières infos bien sûr
sur cette actualité de cette élection
américaine historique renault vous êtes
là oui ça c'est une matinée électorale
extrêmement curieuse à laquelle on
assiste puisque vous l'avez entendu sur
figaro live à 6h45 les deux candidats
sont sont exprimés et considère qu'ils
sont en très bonne voie de gagner
l'élection
vous avez entendu joe biden à 6h45 il
dit deux choses nous sommes en bonne
voie de la gagner cette élection mais
aussi ce n'est pas ce que nous avions
espéré et on garde la foi rapport
évidemment à cette vague bleue démocrate
espérait mais qui n'est pas venu réponse
de trump assez immédiate secours twitter
nous sommes en avance mais il essaye les
démocrates de nouveaux l'élection ne
nous laisserons pas faire ce que vous
pouvez voir en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est cette carte qui est derrière moi
la carte électorale qui s'actualise en
permanence sur lefigaro.fr avec un
enseignement majeur c'est que les
républicains font de la résistance
déjà trois états viennent de basculer
dans le camp républicain depuis quelques
minutes
1 il s'agit du vote de la floride de
l'ohio et de l'iowa
ce qui veut dire que ce compte que vous
voyez ici va changer dans les prochaines
minutes et que le nombre de grands
électeurs des républicains va
progressivement augmenter et en plus il
va continuer d'augmenter parce que il y
à deux états majeurs le texas et la
géorgie où la vence de trump et si nette
que ça lui assure probablement la
victoire
vous allez donc voir le décompte des
grands électeurs côté républicain qui va
augmenter
nous sommes très loin de la vague bleue
espéré par les démocrates la
mobilisation a été très forte
avant le 3 novembre nous étions déjà à
100 millions
on d'avant d'américains qui avaient voté
de manière anticipée
il s'avère que c'était aussi pour
soutenir le président américain très bon
exemple le texas encore une fois qui a
pulvérisé tous les records de
participation et/ou donald trump mène à
l'heure où on se parle avec six points
d'avancé alors qu environ 90% des
bulletins ont été dépouillés l'autre
enseignement et ça c'est un bon point
pour les démocrates c'est l'arizona
l'état qui est ici qui devrait basculer
du camp républicain vers le camp
démocrate
c'est un coup dur un pur trump cette
fois ci parce que l'équipe du président
américain l'avait emporté avec plus de 3
points d'avance en 2016 et au moment où
on se parle byden joe biden à neuf
points d'avancé avec 76 % environ des
bulletins dépouillés
on l'a compris depuis le début de la
matinée tout se jouera comme en 2016
dans les trois états qui sont autour des
grands lacs américains le risque en
chine le michigan et la pennsylvanie et
nous aurons prend peut-être les
résultats dans la matinée mais peut-être
aussi dans les prochains jours vous
savez que les règles du dépouillement
sont différentes d'un état à l'autre et
un dernier mot enfin sur la course au
sénat dont on ne parle peut-être pas
assez mais elle est également très
serrée il y avait 35 sièges en jeu les
démocrates étaient favoris pour
reprendre le contrôle de la chambre
haute
il faudra encore quelques heures pour le
savoir mais c'est crucial cette course
au sénat parce que à quoi bon gagner la
maison blanche s'il sénat est contre
vous ça mène à des paralysies politique
pas possible que le washington a bien
connu ces dernières années
si beaucoup de notes aux filles on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure pour un nouveau
point info avec les derniers résultats
état par état tout à l'heure et vous
nous avez été effectivement dès qu'il y
à des déclarations et des résultats
majeurs à l'instant effectivement comme
vous le disiez l' agence ap hm société
de presse confirme en tout cas selon
elle selon ses projections que donald
trump a remporté le texas ait raflé ses
38 grands électeurs bonjour jean marc
gonin bonjour bonjour jean marc gonin
vous êtes rédacteur en chef au figaro
magazine spécialisé états unis on est
très heureux de vous avoir en plateau ce
matin c'était un moment historique on
peut dire que nous vivons quel regard
vous portez vous sur cette élection bas
l'impression qu'en bégaie un peu quand
même hein parce que on nous avait
annoncé hillary clinton ya quatre ans
nous sommes nous avait annoncé joe biden
ce coup-ci et ben deux fois on voit que
dans l'impasse a déjoué le pronostic est
un peu tôt pour se prononcer tout est
encore sur la ligne de crête on sait pas
de quel côté ça va tomber mais néanmoins
nous avait annoncé une débâcle débâcle
de 30 et des républicains c'est pas le
cas on nous avait annoncé que la géorgie
pourrait basculer
il ya un état qui a basculé c'est
l'arizona qui était effectivement
traditionnellement républicain qui est
devenu démocrate c'est un parfois c'est
un résultat tangible
pour le reste de valve bleus on envoie
des de près ni de loin
on entendait tout à l'heure une auto
fille qui nous parlait de l'enjeu qui
représente aussi l'élection des nouveaux
sièges au sénat c'est l autre bataille
discuter entre les démocrates et les
républicains un renouvellement d'un
tiers des 100 sièges au sénat il ya
trente cinq nouveaux sièges à pourvoir
cette année quel est l'enjeu
concrètement dans cette élection
des ciels des nouveaux sièges au sénat
et les républicains un président qui ne
tient pas le sénat a beaucoup de mal à
gouverner le sénat c'est vraiment une
pièce essentielle du système américain
des checks and balances aux c'est la
partie du législatif qui avait plus
grand pouvoir
khabbach sur la maison blanche d'une
certaine manière qui limite terriblement
le pouvoir la chambre des représentants
est importante pour le budget etc
mais le sénat a vraiment une un point un
poids considérable dans la vie politique
américaine et un président qui un sénat
qui n'est pas de sa couleur à la passe
de sales moments il est obligé de passer
des négociations tout le temps le sénat
approuve les nominations le sénat est ce
que c'est pas face à un sénat qui un peu
verrouiller toutes ces initiatives que
barack obama était empêché on se
souvient dans son premier mandat non
mais attention
bien sûr obama il ya un exemple très
clair on on a vu la différence
obama dans la fin de son mandat avait
jugé a nommé à la cour suprême prendre
cet exemple là les républicains
majoritaires l'urd il n'est pas question
donc de nommer un juge maintenant c'est
fini ou vous êtes vous êtes en fin de
montage et la train plus qu'il y avait
un mandat sénat favorable les mêmes
sénateurs qui pourraient pour les
raisons exactement contraire on dit elle
trois points c'est bon en trois semaines
s'était emballé on va justement
continuer la discussion avec vous jean
marc on va aller encore aux états unis
retrouver un autre de nos envoyés
spéciaux à l'une des personnes qui
avaient bien mis en garde en 2016 que et
qui avait a dit combien une victoire à
l'époque était possible mais pas
beaucoup de journalistes en france qu'il
le faisait et bien laure mandeville en
faisait partie bonjour alors bonjour
comment ça va coûter jusqu'à présent
l'émission suit son cours je rappelle
que vous êtes spécialisé états unis vous
avez été effectivement correspondante
pour le figaro à washington pendant
plusieurs années
on le voit le vote est très serré la
vague bleue la vague buydens n'est pas
au rendez vous pour ce qu'il a souhaité
est est ce qu'on peut considérer que la
personnalité de donald trump et le
personnage de malte rome est une
finalement une une formidable force
politique comme vous l'a affirmé dans un
entretien exclusif il ya quelques temps
dans le figaro magazine walter russell
mead professeur de relations
internationales à barbe college
exactement moi je pense que je le dise
j'écris ça depuis ça fait quatre ans que
je l'écris et et que effectivement
walter russell mead l'a rappelé de
manière assez très clair dans cette
interview 30 a été complètement
sous-estimé comme une force politique
il ne faut pas oublier que trump est
éteint en fait je gauche une révolte et
donc c'est à la fois le phénomène trompe
c'est la rencontre d'une révolte et d'un
homme et et dire que penser que trempe
aller comme ça s'effondrer
ce tte penser que les gens qui avait
derrière lui n'avait pas choisi de le
soutenir pour des raisons profondes et
je pense qu ils tous que ce que c'est
une grave erreur et que ce qu'a montré
cet incroyable comment dire c'est qu'en
ce qu'on a vu depuis quatre ans ou trump
s'est battu a continué à se battre
contre une immense partie des élites
contre pratiquement toute la presse se
liguer contre lui et après contre un
virus et que le fait qu'il n'ait même
pas été abattus par ce virus que la
révolte qui chevauche reste aussi
puissante
à tel point qui va peut probablement
l'emporter en tout cas peut-être
l'emporter demain ou dans les jours qui
viennent
cela montre à quel point on est dans une
crise démocratique et on est face à des
élites qui se sont tellement tromper que
il faut bien en arriver à la conclusion
qu'ils ne connaissent pas leur pays
selon vous si ça veut dire que leur
mondeville ce qu'ils ont sous estimé on
aurait eu tort et que peut-être que son
intuition la fameuse intuition de donald
trump pourrait le mener une nouvelle
fois la victoire
exactement parce que je crois que auront
il a été complètement sous-estimé il a
eu un il a un sens politique incroyable
assez spectaculaire et vous voyez bien
que on a à la fois ans il a continué ce
qu'il avait fait en 2016 c'est pour ça
que tous les gens qui ont couvert 2016
et qui couvrait cette élection
aujourd'hui avait un sentiment de
déjà-vu absolument irrépressible et mais
il y a eu d'autres éléments et notamment
l ouverture qu'il avait vraiment
seulement amorcé en 2016 vers les
minorités ce qui a été complètement sous
traitée dans les journaux américains
parce qu'ils étaient complètement à
charge contre lui c'est que donald trump
a fait une ouverture vers les
populations minoritaires c'est à dire
les noirs les latinos et qu'il a voulu
au fond couper l'herbe sous le pied de
ses adversaires qui l'accusent d'être un
sale raciste qui se moquent complètement
de ces minorités et donc il ya eu un
travail de fond depuis des mois par le
parti républicain pour quadriller en
fait les régions dans lesquelles se
trouvent ces minorités leur quartier
les villes et notamment dans des pays
comme en floride eux en pennsylvanie et
je crois qu'on va voir le fruit en fait
de ce travail s'exprimer ça s'est déjà
exprimée visiblement d'après ce que j'ai
pu comprendre en floride dont on a le
résultat aujourd'hui où on ne peut
expliquer autrement que le résultat qui
est que donald trump a eu notamment dans
un la région de miami est une région
traditionnellement démocrate où hillary
clinton l'avait emporté par 30% des voix
et où byden n'emporte si j'ai bien
compris
en tout cas selon les sondages que par
deux sorties des urnes que par 9% ce qui
voudrait dire que donald trump a gagné
dans cette région de miami des
réservoirs de voix et d'après les
analystes ces réservoirs de voix
seraient notamment des réservoirs de
voix latino une ville vous fait-il
référence à ces noirs qui votent pour
trump à contre-courant de leur
communauté
effectivement de nombreux afro
américains sont sont séduits par le
candidat sortant vous êtes vous même
allé à la rencontre de ses électeurs en
géorgie les détracteurs de trump affirme
qu'un trump est raciste et pourtant
c'est noir vote pour ce candidat
comment on explique cet engouement des
afro américains pour pour donald trump
je crois d'abord il ya énormément de
d'afro américains qui en ont assez d'eux
qu'on ne les associe cas la question du
racisme comme s'ils étaient des victimes
moi j'ai rencontré c'était assez
frappant sur ma route plusieurs
afro-américains qui votait tram qui
m'ont dit nous on en a assez qu'on nous
considère comme des pauvres victimes du
racisme
on est plus il ya 150 ans les temps
changent et nous nous avons un libre
arbitre nous avons des possibilités il
ya eu une grosse bourgeoisie noire les a
évidemment un énorme problème dans les
dix on les classe d'inférieur noires
celles qui sont les plus les plus
démunis qui sont dans les ghettos ça
sert à ça reste un problème énorme mais
ce qu'ils disent que c'est beaucoup plus
un problème socio économique un problème
aussi de d'éducation de famille des
familles complètement désintégrée
que un problème de discrimination
raciale autrement dit
et donc ce soit en plus il faut
comprendre que les afro-américains qui
une fois qu'ils se sont libérés de cette
idée qu'ils doivent voter avec les
démocrates se rendent compte que sur
beaucoup de plans ils sont plus proches
des républicains notamment par leur
valeur puisqu'ils sont en général assez
conservateur très croyant il ya aussi
beaucoup de dôme d'affaires dans la
communauté noire contrairement à ce
qu'on pense beaucoup de une bourgeoisie
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs et ses deux
petits business et vous avez aussi
beaucoup de gens dans les classes
inférieures les plus les plus basses qui
on considère de plus que 30 les aides
avec sa politique migratoire parce
qu'ils se sentent menacés par l'arrivée
d'immigrants illégaux qui eux leur
prennent les emplois auxquels ils
pourraient prétendre et donc il ya
beaucoup d'hommes noirs justement qui
ont voté train pl alors que les femmes
noires ont voté je pense ce plus
largement pour joe biden lors à
l'instant là je vois cet internaute qui
s'appelle conservateur don qui est pas
suspect d'être un anti trump a priori
qui nous dit ce n'est pas du tout gagner
pour trump les votes par correspondance
ont massivement démocrate
non mais c'est peut-être pas gagné pour
30 d'ailleurs il ya encore une
interrogation énorme interrogations sur
l'arizona
une interrogation aussi énorme sur la
pennsylvanie bien sûr et donc il va
falloir attendre que les votes par
correspondance soit dépouillé ils seront
effectivement largement démocrates mais
j'ai pas je dois dire que depuis deux
heures parce que j'étais sur d'autres
plateaux je n'ai pas regardé ce qui se
passait et j'étais dans la rue donc je
ne sais pas où ça en est il faut
effectivement encore être très prudent
mais ce qu'on a en ce qu'on voit déjà
par exemple de par l'analyse par exemple
de la floride
on voit bien qu'il ya des choses qui ne
qui ne qui ne se sont pas produits comme
les sondeurs l'annoncé puisqu'ils nous
avait annoncé un basculement une vague
bleue qui atteindrait le sud et
notamment la floride avec les retraités
qui massivement se déporterait je
voulais souligner d'ailleurs qu' il ya
aussi une question sur est-ce que la
manière dont joe biden a joué cette
carte de la pandémie a été la bonne
parce que on a on n'a plus de batterie
pour laure mandeville alors le suspense
continue héros on espère avoir un petit
peu plus tard dans la journée
l'analyse justement de leur mandeville
sur cette question de la pandémie en
était il ya quelques minutes avant
d'être en ligne avec leurs mondeville
avec jean marc gonin nous parlions dans
des enjeux que représente l'élection des
nouveaux sièges au sénat le
renouvellement des nouveaux sièges
il ya une victoire cette nuit importante
et symbolique celle du sénateur lindsey
graham en caroline du sud qui était un
fervent supporter de donald trump est ce
que c'est une victoire importante et
symbolique
oui parce que là des masses d'argent qui
se sont déversées sur son rival
démocrate les démocrates croyait
vraiment pouvoir déloger une salle g qui
est une figure du sénat
c'est un homme très importants sénateurs
qui étaient dans un tel temps un peu
d'être acteur de 30 au début du mandat
de 30 puisqu'il était le plus proche ami
de du sénateur mccain d'arizona qui est
mort pendant le mandat et puis une fois
que mccain a été enterré g s'est
doucement approché du président jusqu'en
en être un de ses plus fidèles soutiens
et donc beaucoup disaient on va lui
faire payer
alors bon certes la caroline du sud et 1
est un état partie assez sûr pour les
républicains mais néanmoins il était il
était défiée par les démocrates qui
avaient mis des des millions de dollars
derrière son rival qui est un noir
d'ailleurs en pensant le déloger et les
g a gagné par un parent inc une marge
très importante
je voulais voir avec vous jean marc
gonin il ya un autre enjeu électoral
majeur pour trump ce sont les votes de
ceux qu'on appelle les évangéliques
alors c'est 1 1
je sais pas une communauté religieuse
aux états unis qui est assez importante
dans ce pays qui l'est beaucoup moins
dans notre pays est ce qu'on peut donner
un panorama de cet enjeu électoral pour
tom et qui sont ces évangéliques qui ont
autant de succès et qui ont une
influence tout à faire lorsque ce sont
des sons des églises assez récente par
rapport à toutes celles qui existent sur
le sol des états unis et de celle ci en
a mais ce sont des ce sont des cultes
assez récent très moderne entre
guillemets avec des méga des megachurch
des méga églises qui sont très répandus
beaucoup dans le sud et dans l'ouest des
états unis
s'ils sont plus dans le culte du veau
d'or que dans le culte de la comment
dire de la pauvreté du christ on va dire
ça comme ça et qui font boum qui font
beaucoup rêver et qui sont très radicaux
sur leurs principes et trempent a tout
fait pour les soigner pour les garder
dans sa base et plusieurs éléments de
son mandat sont identifiables comme des
concessions faites aux évangéliques une
des plus importantes étant par exemple
le transfert de l'ambassade des états
unis de tel aviv à jérusalem
parce que les évangéliques ont toutes
une thèse sur ce qui va arriver au
moyen-orient une espèce de bataille
finale c est donc il faut absolument que
le côté bibliques d'israël soit
souhaite absolument a démontré par les
états unis et donc il fallait transférer
cette ambassade et quand ça fait un
geste diplomatique d'importance train de
scier même paru vendu il a envoyé comme
par hasard pence mike berry theater g10
qui était le vice-président qui était
l'ancien gouverneur dean viana et qui
est totalement évangélique qui est un
peu le rappelle le signal permanent aux
héros génique que leur que leurs
revendications leurs soucis leurs
législations seront leurs souhaits
seront exaucés et d'ailleurs pendant les
primaires quand j'avais suivi la
campagne de trempe j'étais allé voir
c'est un pasteur très puissant dans le
au sud d'atlanta
je devais dit mais pourquoi vous souvent
qu'homme d'église qui mettait la grille
la morale chrétienne en avant vous
soutenez cet homme qui était dû lutter
qu'elle divorçait plusieurs fois ces
terrains et il m'avait dit vous savez
nous les évangéliques on a servi
d'appoint à trop de présidents
américains républicains qui se sont payé
notre tête
il visait notamment de george bush et à
dire est que celui-ci s'il gagne nouveux
seront exaucés complètement
j'en ai j'en ai l'océan il ya évidemment
l'avortement l'interdiction de
l'avortement
il y a
le recul de la peine de mort dans de
nombreux états il ya toutes sortes de
rencontres la peine de mort non ils sont
pauvres et sans vie d'un poids sont
plutôt pour nom mais il ya il ya toute
une île ont toutes une série de
revendications très clair qu'ils ont
toujours présenté à tous les candidats
républicains qui leur disaient bien
entendu jpj songerait à puis une fois
que c'était arrivé à la maison blanche
sur les tenues à distance alors que 30
avril à ouvrir les portes des
évangéliques qui viennent à la maison
blanche
il y en a tout le temps ça c'est pas
suivi par les médias mais vous avez des
visites de d'évangéliques quasiment 7 6
sur une base hebdomadaire
cette influence des évangéliques elle
existait de quelle façon et dans quelle
proportion sous mandat d'obama elle
existait mais il était républicain de
toute façon dont ils n'étaient pas là et
elle sert critères prêcheur mais lui il
était plutôt dans les airs et reagan qui
a été le premier organe a été le premier
à s'approcher de ces gens là avec jerry
falwell qui était sont une espèce de
deux conseillers qui était un télé
prédicateur célèbre et puis bon c'est
existants ont prospéré d'entre eux
régalés train et 30 à identifier ça
c'est une grande grande astuce électoral
qui lui a permis de d'élargir sa base
parce qu'on dit toujours il ya que les
suprémacistes blancs non il a ce bloc
évangélique qui est quand même qu'ils
représentent
on ne sait pas et vend on sait pas le
chiffrer mais ils vont être vraiment en
bloc et ça représente peut-être 10% de
l'opinion américaine qui est
considérable qu'elle quel regard porte à
joe biden sur sur ces évangéliques de
baden il est catholique donc il est
plutôt sain catholique de la côte est
il est
vues entre la pennsylvanie halle de la
loire s'est pas vraiment sa tasse de thé
si je veux dire c'est quand même ces
églises là sont plutôt entre les deux
candidats sur le rapport qu'ils
entretiennent avec cette communauté
religieuse
ah oui enfin je baille de ne jamais
invectives et les évangéliques il est
prudent mais bon mais catholique en
général les catholiques américains a
perdu votre surnom miley il est croyant
les catholiques américains sont plutôt
considérés dans l'échelon des
l'échelle des noms ils sont plutôt
républicain il semble tout tracé à
l'intérieur vous voyez par exemple le
site de l'ol de l'ohio qui était un
territoire catholique solide frontières
du kentucky
c'est de ceux des gens très très on l'a
vu même dans l'épiscopat américain qui
n'était pas un épiscopat très
progressiste dans toutes les bagarres
qui a au sein de l'église catholique
mondiale et est agréé bien sont plutôt
compter dans le dico qu'observateur
alors en tout cas le nouvel archevêque
de washington lui plutôt plutôt content
premier archevêque noir d'ailleurs est
plutôt opposés à trump sur les questions
d'immigration ambitions on va on va
continuer ses discussions avec vous
jean-marc on va peut-être regarder un
petit peu du côté du bosphore ce qui est
en train de se passer puisque nous avons
delphine minoui qui est en ligne avec
nous delphine est correspondante du
figaro en turquie bonjour dans le film
bonjour quelle est l'ambiance en ce
moment côté turc comment on regarde ces
résultats et surtout comment on regarde
cette cette course incertaine
oui évidemment cette élection elle et
elle est très suivi en turquie mais
étant donné il faut quand même préciser
étant donné le contexte actuel c'est un
suivi qui est quand même assez relatif
il faut rappeler que les yeux de la
turquie sont plutôt centré vers le
centre du pays avec une crise économique
sans précédent qui affecte qui affecte
le pays avec la pandémie aussi du corona
virus qui a qui a rattrapé le territoire
turc
et puis cette tragédie du week end avec
ce grand séisme dans la ville d'izmir
sur la mer egée dont et le bilan ne
cesse d'augmenter on parle maintenant de
200 morts donc si les médias en effet
aujourd'hui en turquie
suivent quand même avec une grande
attention la campagne et far ont suivi
la campagne électorale et continue à
suivre l'élection présidentielle je
dirais que c'est ça suscite largement
moins d'attention que l'élection
américaine précédente où il y avait là à
ce moment là
un enjeu beaucoup plus grand sur
l'élection et sur le scrutin actuel
on veut plutôt qu à ankara où certains
disques en tous les cas où votre est
plutôt trump oui ça a été flagrant au
cours de ces dernières semaines la
presse gouvernementale a vraiment
essentiellement misé sur une réaction de
donald trump et on en parlait beaucoup
dans les médias il y a eu un petit
changement qui s'est opéré au cours de
ces derniers jours où il ya plus une
tendance qui je dirais qui bat dans le
sens de joe biden mais ce qu'on lit en
général ce qu'on entend en général aussi
dans la capitale ankara où je me
trouvais il ya il y a quelques jours
c'est que du point de vue turc
que ce soit l'un ou l'autre des
candidats qui n'emporte ça ne changera
pas grand chose sur le fond sur la forme
évidemment trump est perçu comme une une
personnalité très volatile très
imprévisible c'est très difficile
d'avoir de d'établir des pronostics sur
le long terme
du point de vue du point de vue des
turcs mais mais mais dans l'ensemble il
faut rappeler que du point de vue dans
carré en tout cas il ya une sorte de
traumatisme je dirais avec l'amérique
notamment depuis la tentative de coup
date que de coup d'état raté de l'été
depuis cette époque il y a un énorme aux
différentes rancart et washington
notamment par rapport à cette demande
répéter régulièrement par ankara
d'extrader l'ennemi public numéro 1 des
rohan le prédicateur fethullah gulen qui
est en exil aujourd'hui aux états unis
en pennsylvanie il y a également un gros
différend autour du soutien qu'a
accordée pendant très longtemps les
états unis aux milices kurdes dans son
combat contre des ch
en syrie des ministes urd qui sont
accusés d'être terroriste par ankara et
d'être proche du pkk donc il ya il ya
pas mal de sujets
deux sujets de tension qui ne devrait
pas non plus changé avec une élection de
joe by zen66 la donne change et aux
états unis
peut-être une dernière question delphine
est ce que les soutiens d'erdogan est ce
que les nationale et également les
nationalistes c'est pas toujours les
mêmes ont apprécié la façon dont la
presse américaine par exemple comme le
new york times ont accusé la france d'
excès en matière de laïcité ou la police
d'avoir commis une bavure par exemple en
abattant l'assassin présumé de samuel
pâtit
je suis désolé j'ai mal entendu votre
question est est ce que les soutiens
d'erdogan et est ce que les
nationalistes turcs ont apprécié la
façon dont la presse américaine comme le
new york times accuse la france d excès
en matière de laïcité ou la police
d'avoir commis une bavure en abattant
l'assassin présumé de samuel pâtit
polémique une qu'elle fait polémique en
france
oui évidemment ça s'est il faut le dire
que ça a été ça a été très suivie dans
dans les médias dans les médias turcs et
dans l'est dans les cercles de réflexion
avec un point de vue différent de la
france un point de vue moins tranchées
qui se rapprocherait plus de celui de
celui de la turquie
et c'est vrai que ça permet d'obtenir en
tout cas une troisième voie dans cette
période très délicate de de tension au
plus haut niveau entre la turquie et la
france qui a poussé au rappel temporaire
notamment de l'ambassade dont
l'ambassadeur de france en turquie
qu'est revenue à paris et qui rentrent
rentrée ankara il y à il ya quelques
jours l'un des grands voisins de la
turquie vous l'avez évoqué au sud c'est
bien sûr la syrie est ce qu'une victoire
de joe biden laisserait espérer un
retour des américains dans la région
alors ça c'est une question clé que se
pose tout le monde en général les
observateurs de la région rappelle que
que joe biden a une bien meilleure
connaissance du terrain de la syrie mais
également du moyen orient en général
c'est un sujet qu'il a suivi de très
près quand il était quand il était vice
président d'ailleurs il est également
très connue des cercles de décision y
compris à ankara où on a suivi de très
près le dossier syrien
maintenant l'impression générale c'est
qu'il ya une véritable tendance
américaine au désengagement dans la
région y compris en syrie donc en ce qui
concerne le dossier syrien aujourd'hui
les trois principaux parrains d'une
potentielle résolution politique à
l'avenir ce sont la turquie la russie et
l'iran et aujourd'hui les états unis
aussi bien que l'europe d'ailleurs sont
considérés comme étant complètement hors
jeu
merci beaucoup delphine pour toutes ces
précisions pour 7 pour cet éclairage et
je rappelle que vous êtes donc là la
correspondante du figaro et à istanbul
et en attend de lire justement comment
l'élection américaine sont la certitude
de son issue est vue
d'istanbul c'est à regarder à suivre
dans les prochaines heures sur le site
du figaro jean-marc peut-être avant
qu'on se quitte cette question
de braise on sent venir une bataille
juridique au niveau des caures des
résultats par rapport au vote par
correspondance est ce que c'est ce que
vous craignez elle aura lieu
indiscutablement parce que il ya à peu
près pareil ne serait-ce qu'en
pennsylvanie
ça représente un million de voix est là
pour l'instant à l'heure où nous parlons
et je crois qu'ils en ont dépouillé que
300000 donc ça va prendre un temps fou
et évidemment vincent biron a senti qu
trempe
avant même sa la compagne de 30 a déposé
des recours devant plusieurs tribunaux
dans les états donc on peut on peut
imaginer que la bataille juridique
montera jusqu'à la cour surprême pour
cette course à thème pour certains états
et c'est donc ce comptage risque de
durer très longtemps et d'être contestée
effectivement surtout quand on part du
principe que les votes par
correspondance sont plutôt des votes
démocrates puisque le parc de d'habitude
ils sont républicains mais là l'histoire
du coc vide l'électorat démocrate a été
beaucoup plus sensibilisés c'est donc
évident que l'électorat républicain est
avec toi républicain s'est déplacé pour
voter alors que l'électorat démocrate a
mis sa voix la boîte aux lettres jean
marc gonnet vous citiez l'état de
pennsylvanie qui est un état swing
states en état pivot
l'enjeu est considérable sur cet état
dans les heures qui arrivent
et à propos de cet état est ce que joe
biden pourrait le perdre du fait de son
intervention lors du débat numéro 2 son
dernier débat face à donald trump il a
parlé d' un retrait progressif à terme
de l'extraction du pétrole et
l'exploitation du pétrole et cesson la
pennsylvanie fait partie de ces états
pétroliers et gaziers du nord des états
unis ça pourrait jouer en sa défaveur
d'avoir annoncé ça c'est un élément
c'est une bourde d'ailleurs on a vu
comment les républiques les démocrates
ensuite se sont précipités sur les micro
pour dire non non il n'y a pas dit ça et
c'est cette idée de transition
de sortir pour progressif du pétrole et
dans la partie occidentale de la
pennsylvanie il ya beaucoup de gaz de
pétrole de schiste ça a apporté pas mal
de la prospérité dans le coin et sahar
donner du travail à des gens qui n'en
avaient plus donc effectivement c'était
une grosse boulette et je pense que s'il
doit le payer en ce moment j'ai vu aussi
que dans l'ohio qui est pourtant moins
concernés mais le vote des syndicalistes
alors qu'ils avaient semblé pour les
démocrates qui leur semblait acquis est
les sondages de sortie des urnes dans
l'ohio john 52% pour 30 46 % pour baydan
chez les syndiqués dans l'ohio l'ohio la
pennsylvanie ces sondes et sociologique
qui se rassemblent une toute dernière
question jean marc avant de recevoir
nicolas baverez
on a suivi l'élection de trump avec vous
vous étiez déjà là en 2016 on avait
suivi son investiture en le 20 janvier
à cette époque trump avait dit ceux qui
sont sans voix en amérique finalement
sont présents à la maison blanche par ma
voix en substance ça avait frappé
c'était un discours de combat
quatre ans après est ce qu'on peut pas
dire que finalement cette stratégie pour
qu'il vende qu'elle a été à fonctionner
elle a fonctionné elle continue de
fonctionner contre toute attente c'est à
dire que on peut pas dire vraiment qu'il
ait fait beaucoup pour les jeux les sans
voix dont il parle tout le temps il a
fait beaucoup pour lui et sa famille pas
beaucoup pour les sans voix
mais ces gens-là qu'on se continue à
aimer cet homme qui ce qui dit être
contre washington contre les experts
contre tous ceux qui les ont fait
souffrir et il reste leur champion c'est
clair merci beaucoup
jean-marc jan margot n'at on va faire un
peu à une synthèse
des derniers résultats des dernières
informations
charlotte peut-être donné la lecture
avant que nicolas baverez arrive de
certains commentaires d'internautes vous
continuez à poser vos questions vous
continuez à nous donner vos réactions en
ce moment vous êtes modéré par jean
baptiste émergents sur le site du figaro
ça y est j'ai perdu vos commentaires
mais je vais les retrouver
je salue notamment cet internaute qui se
dit personne n'écoute mais si on écoute
et on lit ce que vous dites et brest
2012 qui a un internaute fidèles du
figaro finalement les états unis ne sont
pas un état laïque nous dit cet autre
internet
on sent donc venir une bataille
juridique les gens votent pour leur
porte-monnaie vous nous dites également
ça on va voir c'est
c'est ce que justement en pense un
certain nombre de commentateurs et de
spécialistes peut-être nicolas baverez
ce qui est en train de rentrer sur ce
plateau qu'on les remercie qu'on est
content d'avoir bonjour nicolas et puis
on
on signale également donc les dernières
projections on disait tout à l'heure que
asus est de presse donnée donc donald
trump vainqueur en floride
en revanche l'arizona qui avait été
remporté lors du précédent scrutin
on part donald trump est finalement
tombée dans l'escarcelle de joe biden
vous avez tous les résultats bien sûr en
temps réel sur le site du figaro avec la
carte interactive mise en place par le
fic data et les résultats que l'on vous
donne également pendant cette
conversation vous continuez à nous poser
vos questions à réagir on les scrute
avec charlotte barillon et on va opposer
certaine à nicolas baverez ce bonjour
nicolas merci d'être avec nous peut-être
un commentaire une réaction sur sur la
situation actuelle sur cette incertitude
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire deux
choses d'abord c'est le pire des
scénarios c'est à dire qu' on n'est pas
du tout dans une élection qui va être
tranchée vite et bien
on n'est pas du tout dans le scénario
majoritaire qu'avaient imaginés les
médias les sondages et les marchés qui
était le scénario dit de la vague bleue
ça on sait déjà que ça n'est pas le cas
donc finalement on se retrouve avec une
structure qui va sans doute tenir de
l'élection de 2016 et de celle de 2000
l'élection de 2016 puisque tout va se
jouer dans les fameux trois états du
middle west pennsylvanie michigan
wisques en chine et wisconsin
donc c'est exactement la structure de
2016 et il va y avoir un petit côté 2000
parce que compte tenu du fait que les
votes par correspondance de ces états
vont être dépouillés après le
la date d'aujourd'hui il est certain
qu'on a un risque très élevé de
contentieux enchaîne donc voilà les
voilà les deux éléments la vraie
conclusion à en tirer c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'ont voulu croire
beaucoup de gens trump n'est pas un
accident
quel que soit le résultat on voit que
l'amérique
on s'était dit que c'était trump était
une sorte d'aberration que sa victoire
devait beaucoup aux faiblesses de
hillary clinton
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui avec ce
scrutin quel que soit le vainqueur
c'est que l'amérique a bougé de manière
beaucoup plus profonde est que même en
cas d'ailleurs de victoire finalement de
baden c'est cette amérique avec cette
amérique là qui va falloir essayer de
reconstruire le monde des démocraties du
21e siècle et c'est une amérique qui n'a
rien à voir avec celle de 1945 donc une
des grandes leçons pour les européens
c'est que finalement pourquoi est ce que
les européens adorent hebeisen pas ce
que c'est
ils ont projeté une espèce de social
démocratie européenne sur bail donne ce
qui était d'ailleurs une erreur mais ça
de toute manière cette en dehors du
champ de l'amérique on voit que très
profondément
l'amérique profonde refuse de toute
manière ce modèle et tous ceux qui ont
cru coup et qui ont misé parce que la
politique européenne est en grande
partie suspendu aux résultats de cette
élection et les beaucoup de dirigeants
et de pays européens se disaient biden
va gagner et on revient au monde de
l'amérique de 45 ça de toute manière
cette élection je pense que c'était déjà
faux avant et il cette élection l acte
vraiment que c'est une erreur
fondamentale plus profondément bon vois
pas ce que j'ai pour l'instant ce livre
être au jeu des pronostics nicolas vous
avez dans une chronique récente du
figaro celle qu'on peut retrouver dans
l'édition papier de chaque lundi écrit
que la polarisation de la société est
attisée par la guerre culturelle qui va
jusqu'à remettre en cause les fondements
de la nation américaine
oui mais c'est ce qu'ont d'ailleurs ce
qu'on risque de ce qu'on risque de voir
après si vous voulez c'est la première
quand même
c'est la première fois lors d'une
élection américaine qu'on voit tous les
centres des grandes villes
barricadé avec des magasins qui sont
avec lui qu'on signale pas de meute
qu'un nom mais on signale pas mais il
fait il faut quand même entendre ce
genre de signaux c'est ce qui est arrivé
en france avec les gilet jaune mais à
l'échelle des états unis dans les
grandes villes
ddd deux côtes donc le climat de cette
élection de toute façon n'a pas
d'équivalent on a connu des élections
qui ont été extrêmement disputée mais on
n'a jamais vu un contexte pareil
et là encore quand on dit je pense que
le scénario 2000 il y avait eu cette
grande tension judiciaire mais cette
fois ci je pense que si on est dans une
élection qui finit par être tranché par
la cour suprême
de toute manière ce sera très différente
2000 parce qu'en 2000 finalement al gore
avait accepté sa défaite alors que
vraisemblablement il était le vainqueur
je pense que cette fois ci compte tenu
de ce qui s'est passé à la cour suprême
et de sa composition actuelle si
finalement je pense qu'une très forte
chance que le
le vaincu quels qu'ils soient n'accepte
pas la décision de la cour suprême
notamment que des démocrates considèrent
que cette cour suprême n'est plus
légitime pour trancher de l'élection
donc on est vraiment entré dans un monde
qui est très différent de celui de qu'on
avait connue finalement l'équation qui
était que les états unis étaient exercer
le leadership mondial ça s'est fini déjà
depuis
en tout cas depuis obama mais soit obama
ça s'est fait de manière plutôt ordonné
et discrète bon ça c'est terminé
mais l'idée que les états unis ce mois
là fait quand même un des éléments qui
avait amené à la victoire de trump qui
avait fait quand même on se rappelle son
slogan de campagne en 2016 c'était
rendre sa grandeur à l'amérique
oui mais mais ça enfin c'est un
excellent slogan il est clair que tout
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
par ailleurs en termes de donald trump a
démantelé toutes les structures du
leadership américain
aimer l'autre aspect qui est devant nous
et qui est très important c'est que
l'amérique était exerçait leadership du
monde et l'amérique était à la fois la
démocratie exemplaire la nation
indispensable et le pays qui
garantissait la démocratie dans le monde
et ça avec le panda de donald trump
c'était déjà très abîmé il va de soi que
s'il ya deux présidences trump ça s'est
terminé
joe biden a fait un article dans foreign
policy où il a titré rendre son
leadership
aux états unis il ya quand même cette
ambition chez joe biden est ce qu'ils
peuvent faire c'est ça qui le dit mais
je pense que tu as toute une partie des
structures de toute manière parce que
trump correspond je le répète à une
évolution profonde de l'amérique donc le
retour au protectionnisme ça démocrates
et républicains sont s'est aligné
l'opposition très ferme à la chine c'est
la même chose simplement les démocrates
le font par ailleurs avec
sur le plan des valeurs aussi alors que
trump est uniquement du côté d d d
intérêt et le retrait des états unis de
toute manière le retrait notamment
d'europe et du moyen-orient il faut être
clair ça a commencé avec obama ça et pas
du tout avec trump qu'il a accéléré et
et le fait que l'amérique réinvesti
surtout dans la zone indo pacifique ça
de toute manière ça se poursuivra que ce
soit baden où que ce soit trump le style
en revanche est très différent et ce qui
importe beaucoup pour l'europe c'est que
autant le parce que chez trump il ya non
seulement le fait de mépriser les alliés
qu'ils soient des ures asiatiques comme
le japon ou là mais il ya une vraie
haine de l'union européenne et une
détestation de l'otan aussi ce qui est
paradoxal c'est pour ça que poutine
adore trump c'est que le trump est en
train de faire ce que staline et tous
les autres avaient rêvé mais que le et
donc ça on ne l'aura pas chez by donne
donc le style vis-à-vis des alliés sera
différent les alliés asiatiques seront
sûrement beaucoup plus ménagé parce
qu'ils sont très importants en face à la
chine est par ailleurs y aura pas cette
détestation de principe au nom de tous
qui est multilatérale contre le temps et
contre l'union européenne alors il y
avait il ya une région quand même où on
aime
donald trump et que donald trump en tout
cas aime bien c'est le proche-orient
charlotte et oui on file tout de suite à
jérusalem où nous attend thierry oberlé
correspondant du figaro sur place
bonjour thierry bon jeu
m'entendais pas ça y est c'est revenu
thierry selon un sondage récent paru il
ya quelques jours plus de 60 % des
israéliens ont jugé préférable la
réélection de donald trump pour un
second mandat plutôt que la victoire de
son adversaire joe biden comment on
explique cette popularité de donald
trump sur l'électorat juif israélien
oui les israéliens s'intéressent
beaucoup et cette élection parce que le
battery mais là vous à travers un prisme
qui est israélo israélien il s'interroge
4 vont être les conséquences pour israël
est effectivement selon un sondage de
plus de 60 % des israéliens sont en
faveur du président sortant
et c'est un score qui monte même jusqu'à
80% si on tient pas compte du secteur
arabe israélien alors cette trempe magna
elle se elle se elle passe par des
défilés de voitures c'est un des rares
pays au monde où les supporters de trump
défilent en voiture à jérusalem comme
ils le font aux états unis et puis il ya
aussi eu les colons les colons les plus
extrémistes c'est à dire ceux de hébron
sont allés prier pour 30 au tombeau des
patriarches
alors comment cela s'explique c'est que
pour la majorité des israéliens
donald trump et le président qui a été
le plus favorable à leur payer et dans
les faits leur donnent raison puisque
donald trump et a pris les décisions
symboliques comme de transférer
l'ambassade des états unis de canal
vivent à jérusalem il a également
reconnu l'annexion du golan et puis
aussi il a pris des décisions politiques
importantes c'est-à-dire il s'est retiré
comme le souhaitait les israéliens du de
l'accord sur une clairière iranien il a
défendu un plan de paix qui pour
l'instant n'aboutit pas mais qui et qui
est très favorable à israël est très
défavorable aux palestiniens et enfin il
c'est très important
il a fermé les yeux tant qu'il n'a pas
encouragé la poursuite et même
l'accélération de la colonisation en
cisjordanie
et cette colonisation en fait la
solution à deux états très improbable
benjamin benyamin netanyahou le premier
ministre israélien se plaît à dire de
l'actuel locataire de la maison blanche
qu'il est le plus grand ami qu'israël
n'ait jamais eue n'ai jamais eu
la défaite de donald trump est ce
qu'elle ne signerait pas aussi celle du
premier ministre israélien qui a
toujours affiché effectivement son
entente avec donald trump
oui enfin s'il ya une victoire de trump
elle sera par ricochet une un succès
pour netanyahu parce que lorsque
netanyahu est là a dit un jour lorsque
traque commence une phrase je peux la
terminer donc il ya vraiment cette
proximité qui fait que mais qui fait
qu'il est qu'il ait qu'une défaite de
byden le mettrait en difficulté mais
dans le même temps il a été assez
prudent lorsque il ya eu cette
conversation téléphonique chine mais au
moment des accords d'annoncer des
accords avec de paix avec le soudan le
train plus à poser un piège il a dit tu
penses que jabbari des 90 l'endormi
aurait pu conclure ce marché et
netanyahou a été prudent il a dit
monsieur le président je peux vous dire
que nous apprécions l'aide pour la paix
de quiconque en amérique donc d'une
certaine manière il
il se protège et en cas de victoire de
bryden bien sûr ce serait perçu comme
une gifle mais en même temps il a
l'habitude aussi des présidents
démocrates
il a il était déjà premier ministre
lorsque clinton était président il était
premier ministre lorsque obama était
président et ça se passait très mal avec
obama mais en même temps et dont le vice
président était joe biden mais en même
temps ils allaient les etats-unis ont
toujours considéré en israël comme un
allié stratégique et ils ont fait
pression sur eux et ils le feront sans
doute pour que les israéliens reviennent
comme les palestiniens à un dialogue en
vue d'un règlement de leur conflit
mais lille et les ide a l'habitude en
cas de surdose situation de la méthode
trump qui consista à tordre le bras de
ses adversaires et parfois même de ses
partenaires pour obtenir ce qu'il veut
c'est la main c'est la méthode à
laquelle il a eu recours aussi avec
netanyahu non il n'a pas eu besoin il
n'aurait pas eu besoin parce que c'était
sûr ils sont sur la même longueur d'onde
netanyahu a coutume de dire lorsque je
demande quelque chose enfin il donne
l'image de quelqu'un qui lorsqu'ils
demandent quelque chose à donald trump
donald trump accepte en revanche donald
trump utilisent cette méthode avec les
palestiniens
et il a essayé de leur tordre le buzz le
bras lorsque les palestiniens ont refusé
de discuter de son plan qui était à
l'époque en préparation et bien qu'est
ce qu'il a fait il a fermé il a fermé le
la représentation des palestiniens
washington et surtout il leur a coupé
les vivres il n'y a plus du tout la baie
des centaines de millions de dollars qui
était qui permettait à l'autorité
palestinienne de se développer
il a maintenant il n'y a plus il n'y a
plus un dollar est ce qu'une victoire de
joe biden renforcerait les relations
entre les palestiniens et washington au
détriment de l'état hébreu elle maudit
allait modifier un peu la donne le un
des conseillers de du président abbas a
dit que le président us le président
américain et le pire président pour
notre cause et qu'il souhaite qu'il s'en
aille maintenant c'est peut-être un voeu
pieux et messi vraiment byden
l'emportent ça ne veut pas dire que on
reviendra un statu quo d'antan le bail
deyn a annoncé qu'il ne venait pas
question de de l'ambassade des états
unis retourne à tel aviv
il ya les accords avec les pays arabes
entre israël et les pays arabes qui
seront soutenus toujours par les états
unis des accords qui sous-entendent que
on peut s'entendre avec avec israël sans
pour autant qu'il ya une paix avec les
palestiniens et et enfin de y voit les
palestiniens voient bien sur 7
une victoire de baden comme une bouée de
sauvetage mais ils sont sur le plan
diplomatique très isolé et à court
d'argent
divisés donc bien sûr ça les arrangerait
mais ça ne peut pas dire que le braille
den den ne reviendra à une situation en
situation précédent merci beaucoup de
séries oberlé pour vos éclairages et
votre présence en direct aujourd'hui
dans cette matinale dédiée à l'élection
américaine n'a très bientôt sur notre
site lefigaro.fr figaro live merci
beaucoup
thierry et on suivra également donc le
récit de deux tubes et relisent dans les
heures à venir finalement les états unis
ne sont pas un état laïc du 10è cet
internaute sur sur figaro live tout à
l'heure sont discutées gestion du poids
des évangélistes et on les états unis
n'ont jamais été un état laïc
tocqueville avait déjà vu quand il y est
allé en 1831 le président des états unis
prête serment sur la bible et la manière
dont les états unis ont été dans les
pères fondateurs
on imaginait la liberté politique
contrairement à la france c'est une
liberté politique qui est ancré dans des
valeurs dans des valeurs religieuses
on aura vu donc la meilleure placement
de produit et vient de faire nicolas
baverez puisqu'il a écrit un livre
excellent qu'on leur demande
le monde selon tocqueville le livre que
vous avez écrit c'est celle alerte
démocratique
on peut dire que ce matin on est en
pleine alerte démocratique
cette alerte elle devient même rouge
écarlate avec ce qui se passe aux etats
unis
oui bien sûr on le savait déjà c'est
il ya toute une série de chocs qui ont
touché les démocraties etc démocratie
n'était pas du tout prête à les
affronter puisqu'on était quand même
dans l'illusion de la fin de l'histoire
de la fin de la violence de la fin des
rapports de force et donc ces régimes
qui après la chute de l'union soviétique
ont cru que le monde et l'avenir est à
eux se sont trouvés confrontés aux pires
craintes depuis 1929 à des vagues
d'attentats terroristes
à partir de 2001 et donc le surgissement
du jihadisme aux ambitions de puissance
de nouveaux empires la chine la russie
la turquie vous en avait parlé
et puis à une épidémie majeure et donc
de fait aujourd'hui il y as l'impression
d'une perte de contrôle
face à l'épidémie
face à l'économie face et aux inégalités
sociales face aux problèmes d'ordre
public intérieur et face à la montée de
la chine
donc c'est vrai que trump a très bien
compris ça et à apporter une réponse qui
est la réponse des hommes forts des
démagogues dans ce genre de
circonstances mais il a su le faire et
ce qu'on voit avec cette élection est ce
qui a été beaucoup sous-estimé y compris
par les médias américains et beaucoup
d'analystes c'est que trump parle à
l'amérique profonde et trump a réussi à
inscrire ce discours alternatif
ce discours démagogiques et fondé quand
même sur un rapport très distendue à la
vérité tout en incarnant des valeurs de
l'amérique et il faut reconnaître que le
par ailleurs sa campagne et y compris le
la manière dont il a dont il a réussi à
retourner le fait qu'ils avaient été
malades les sa campagne est assez
extraordinaire par son degré de
d'énergie et les angles qu'il a su
trouver justement ça
la question de tout des dards qui sont
je le vous posez vous avez dit vous nous
l'avez redit ce matin que avec trump en
tous les cas il n'a pas restaurer le
leadership américain est au contraire on
a même le déclin s'est poursuivie sinon
à accélérer mais pourtant avec ce que
l'on voit même en ce moment même c'est à
dire que pour l'instant on est dans
l'incertitude alors que toutes les
moyennes de sondages tous les
indicateurs montrent et disait affirmé
prétendait que baye donne ne pouvait que
gagner et qu'il y avait que
l'incertitude finalement que ce qui
s'était passé en 2016 qui pouvait
remettre ça en cause
trump pour l'instant fait mentir cette
certitude serait supportable en tout cas
cette certitude
est ce que justement il incarne pas et
il continue pas d'incarner cette idée
américaine de rien et rien n'est gravé
dans le marbre tous les espoirs sont
sans permis le succès peut être au
rendez vous et c'est quand même ça l'adn
et de la dynamique américaine et du lit
n'est pas américain dans le monde
non mais je crois que les deux questions
sont dissociés il te fait pas de doute
que ce que j'ai indiqué c'est à dire que
le l'amérique n'est pas social démocrate
et le sera jamais c'est pas les valeurs
des états unis et donc donald trump
parle à toute une partie de l'amérique
avec ce goût de la liberté ce goût du
combat
le fait que l'économie et la liberté
individuelle sont pour lui plus
important que par exemple une politique
de santé publique
et ça c'est très peu compréhensible en
europe et c'est vrai qu'il parle aux
états unis mais c'est complètement
dissociés la question du leadership donc
que et qu'il est construit d'ailleurs
puisque finalement ces quatre années ont
été quatre années de campagne électorale
al'inverse dans le même temps c'est vrai
qu'il a complètement démanteler tout ce
qui faisait les relais à l'extérieur de
la puissance américaine et il a ouvert
un formidable espace en réalité à la
chine
on l'a
c'est la première fois que dans une
grande crise les états unis n'existe pas
et que la chine est sur le devant de la
scène
il a ouvert aussi d'énormes espaces avec
à la russie et à erdogan dont il est
très proche
à titre personnel on l'a vu tout à
l'heure l'alertent démocratique c'est
votre dernier livre édition de
l'observatoire
oui le monde selon tocqueville
tocqueville hauteur de la démocratie en
amérique
il est bientôt 8h02 on va tout de suite
retrouvé au no tô fier pour les derniers
points sur les résultats est à part et
arnaud vous êtes la wii et la
présidentielle américaine vous le
comprenez qui est suspendu un décompte
des voix dans une poignée d'états ou
pour tout pourrait se jouer
c est taillé s'appelle le whisky gin le
michigan et la pennsylvanie trois états
que trump a gagné de justesse en 2016
à l'heure où l'on se parle le président
américain a une solide avance en
pennsylvanie avec 15 points d'avance
également dans louise consignes avec 9
points avec quatre points d'avancé et
dans le michigan avec 9 points d'avance
mais attention charlotte car dans ces
états les bulletins arrivée par
correspondance ou de manière anticipée
vont continuer à être dépouillés dans
les prochaines heures et on sait que ce
sont des voies qui sont normalement
al'avantage du parti démocrate parce que
les sympathisants démocrates ont
largement plébiscité le vote par
correspondance et le vote par
anticipation la carte que vous voyez
derrière moi maintenant on y jette un
coup d'oeil ensemble comme promis un le
décompte des grands électeurs côté
républicain qui a grimpé pendant l'heure
écoulée la quasi-totalité des états qui
ont été annoncé comme serré ont en
réalité tourné à la faveur du président
républicain et du président américain
pardon exemple dans le texas qu'on
annonce une course serrée et bien trump
à six points d'avance dans l'ohio on
annonce une course serrée président
trump a pour l'instant huit points
d'avancé et dans l'iowa
c'est la même chose et ses sept points
d'avancé vous voyez donc qu'il y à une
nouvelle déroute des instituts de
sondage
en tout cas pour les sondages qui ont
été fait état par état
histoire d'ajouter un peu d'incertitude
à cette matinée où règle déjà un épais
brouillard
les deux candidats à la présidence à
6h45 heure française qui ont tous les
deux estimé qu'ils étaient en bonne voie
de remporter la présidentielle
on garde la foi a dit joe biden malgré
les résultats insatisfaisants du parti
démocrate et nous sommes devant ils
essaient de nous voler l'élection a
répondu donald trump en parlant des
démocrates sur twitter dans la foulée
d'intervention joe biden que vous avez
pu entendre sur figaro live en direct à
8h ce que l'on peut dire c'est qu'il y a
un pressentiment qui domine que le
résultat de cette élection ne sera pas
connu ce matin mais peut-être plus tard
dans la journée peut-être même dans les
prochains jours c'était un scénario qui
était largement anticipé 1 par certains
analystes parce que oui il ya eu la
pandémie parce que le vote par
correspondance a été largement anticipée
qu'il faut donc plus de temps pour
recevoir ces bulletins les dépouiller et
puis comme chaque voix compte comme
l'élection est serrée il faudra aussi
attendre un nombre important de
contentieux juridique de recompte des
voix de recours juridiques de la part
des deux camps qui pourraient aller
parfois jusqu'à la cour suprême
ce que je veux ce que je peux vous dire
en revanche à 8 heures avec certitude
cette fois ci c'est que kanye west qui
se rêvait tant troisième homme pour
cette présidentielle américaine ne
deviendra pas le 45e président des états
unis
merci renaud et vous donner la réponse
à qui était attendue par nos internautes
attention je m'entends neko enguerrand
renault nous a rejoints enguerrand avant
qu'on vous donne la parole juste une
précision une information va peut-être
vous la coupe est très vite parce que il
y à un pupitre qui se prépare du côté de
chez trump nous annonce-t-on et donc on
devrait peut-être entendre l'actuel
président américain s'exprime et en tous
les cas on vous le fera vivre en direct
bonjour en iran bonjour bonjour en gamme
renault je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef médias et technologie
au figaro la campagne entre les deux
candidats aura été
une violence inouïe les candidats seront
mener une véritable guerre par spot télé
interposés et communication sur sur les
réseaux sociaux une campagne aussi dont
le coût atteint un record historique on
parle de 1 milliard et demi pratiquement
de dollars par candidat on va dire par
comparaison pour emmanuel macron c'était
16 millions d'euros pour la campagne
présidentielle comment on explique ces
sommes considérables pour les candidats
américains bas aux états unis il lève
beaucoup d'argent ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment important et intéressant c'est
que sur ce milliard et demi par candidat
beaucoup sont allés sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que là on voit que c'est
c'est la guerre de l'info qui ces
ouvriers sur les réseaux sociaux surtout
surtout pour convaincre les jeunes on
l'a vu il ya beaucoup de sondage plus
d'un tiers des jeunes sa forme quasiment
exclusivement sur les réseaux sociaux
sur cette élection
loin devant la télé qui elle regagne
encore toute la publicité une grande
majorité de publicité va toujours sur la
télé qui coûte le plus cher l'achat
d'espacé publicitaire c'est énorme cette
énorme effectivement on peut faire des
despotes pas très très cher sur youtube
beaucoup qui est une filiale de google
et sur sur facebook
il faut signaler que twitter avait
refusé cette publicité politique pour
éviter d'être embringué dans dans les
difficultés
donc effectivement c'est la housse
informe les jeunes c'est la housse ou se
fait l'opinion
c'est là où parle beaucoup donald trump
donc ça a eu une importance très très
très grande
dans ces élections alors justement vous
parlez de ces réseaux sociaux qui ont eu
un rôle conséquent pendant cette cette
campagne contrairement à 2016 un
facebook et instagram ont été on va dire
mieux préparés en 2020 pour faire face
aux tentatives d'ingérence sur le
scrutin
concrètement comment comment ils ont
procédé on a vu ce matin justement sur
l'un des deux messages tweets et très
rapidement par donald trump que l un des
deux otages a été signé
et bloquer censuré dirait donald trump
voilà c'est l'un des procédés qui a mis
en place twitter par rapport aux
ingérences possible oui alors twitter et
facebook effet ils ont dit qu'ils
feraient extrêmement attention là dans
cette période incertaine extrêmement
attention à ce que pour bloquer les
messages qui annoncerait une victoire
d'un camp ou d'un autre oui donc ça il
l'avait dit ça le paradoxe vraiment et
ce matin on a pu le voir c'est là que
joe biden a pris la parole et sur la
télé la radio dont qu'il a il a été
libre et la réponse de donald trump qui
était on essaie de nous voler notre
victoire
elle a été censuré donc on est sur un
paradoxe il ya plus de son sur ce matin
et peut-être dans les prochaines heures
sur les réseaux sociaux que sur les
médias traditionnels
est ce qu'il ya un parti pris des
réseaux sociaux alors ça c'est c'est
intéressant tout le monde tout le monde
enfin les deux candidats ont dit
qu'effectivement ils ont crié à la
censure
il est fait il est vrai que les réseaux
sociaux sont californien ils sont plutôt
d'ascendance démocrate est ce que est ce
qu'ils ont censuré pour autant donald
trump c'est assez difficile a dit à
focale juste dire on l'a vu un twitter
c'est le canal officiel d'informations
de données comme donc on peut pas dire
qu'il a été censurée et ça ça fait plus
de quatre ans voilà mais un certain
nombre de fois ce qui l'a rendu fou de
rage et donc il
après ces signalements il a dit qu'il
allait réformer une loi qui s'appelle la
section de 130 qui est une loi très
particulière qui date de 1996 et qui
organise lire responsabilité juridique
des réseaux sociaux sur les contenus
qu'ils qu'il véhicule et donc après
avoir été censuré comme il le dit par
twitter il a dit je vais changer cette
loi il ya des auditions au sénat en ce
moment sur sur ça mais on verra le
résultat de l'élection savoir qui de
trump ou de biden va réguler les gaffes
à certains dénoncent les réseaux sociaux
comme étant en particulier facebook un
danger pour la démocratie
oui c'était un danger pour la démocratie
parce qu'effectivement c'est c'est un
réseau social sur laquelle s'exprime
beaucoup de haine on l'a vu est partout
en france aussi c'est un problème alors
ils ont mis en place ddd de la
modération à la fois ils ont embauché
énormément de personnes pour modérer
donc physiquement et puis ils ont
développé ce qu'on appelle des
algorithmes des programmes qui détecte
en amont les contenus haineux il affirme
en effet que news avec news avait quand
les contenus haineux ils affirment
qu'ils en bloc en amant 90%
donc quand on voit les 10 % qui sont
déjà assez énorme on a très très peur de
ce qui se passe effectivement derrière
jean garon renault je voulais voir avec
vous également le l'état des médias et
de la presse aux etats unis 4 après
quatre ans de mandat de de donald trump
finalement ces médias américains et or
ont été renforcées par par ce mandat de
donald trump
alors ça c'est le deuxième paradoxe aux
états unis en 2016 les médias et la
presse américaine était quasiment
exemple vous le dire et puis est arrivé
donald trump et là ça l'esprit c'est une
bouffée d'oxygène pour les médias et
surtout les médias qui tapait sur donald
trump c'est à dire essentiellement le
new york times et le washington post qui
appartient à jeff bezos
celui qui possède également amazon et la
lutte contre donald trump a porté ses
médias à des niveaux extraordinaires par
exemple on il ya quasiment 6 millions
d'abonnés numériques ou new york times y
en avait à peine un million et demi en
et ça c'est l'engagement alors c'est la
difficulté c'est à la fois alors
meilleur ennemi
et puis ça veut dire que la question qui
se pose est fière alors aujourd'hui on
ne sait pas on est dans l'incertitude
mais s'il ya plus donald trump est ce
qu'on continuera à être aussi soutenue
parce que les élections seront les mêmes
est ce que les afghans seront les mêmes
on peut s'interroger si donald trump
n'est pas évident que va devenir foxnews
là bas c'est ça non non alors ça de non
non c'est assez étonnant c'est plutôt
une solution mais voilà en fait on dans
les
lien c'est ce qu'on appelle les médias
ce gros nieuws et les médias qui sont
contre le pouvoir en place qui profitent
et les médias qui sont dans le camp du
pouvoir en place
en règle générale ne profite pas il faut
que nous a plutôt bien résisté alors
c'est des chaînes d'info on s'appelait
noms sont énormes cnn et fox news
c'est quand même d honneur ce qu'ils
sont pas énormes il faut il faut il faut
quand même avoir cette cette idée en
tête c'est rien comparé à un jt de 20
heures de tf1 par exemple les audiences
au filet pour les audiences di figaro
relate exactement mais fox news est un
paradoxe dans le paradoxe il a bien
résisté comment on imagine que les
médias se comporteront dans le cas d'un
second mandat de donald trump à ce que
les médias la presse les chaînes de
télévision seront encore plus virulentes
à l'égard de donald trump où se trouvera
une sorte de statu quo c'est difficile
pour gagner de l'audience foyers non on
est on est dans une finition d'une
société polarisée jusqu'où c'est ça la
la la la question et puis il faut quand
même se rendre compte que tous les
scoops toutes les affaires qui sont
sorties n'ont eu aucune implication sur
l'opinion publique américaine la preuve
là aujourd'hui on était persuadé qu'il y
aurait un raz de marée démocrate il n'en
est rien donc en fait il
on a l'impression que il travaille
beaucoup ils sont beaucoup d'affaires
mais ce fameux quatrième pouvoir qui
avait mis à mal on s'en souvient nixon
n'est plus vraiment là peut-être je me
permets d'intervenir la discussion mais
bien eu un parti pris en tous les cas
qui a très bien montré leur mandeville
danser dans ses reportages
la nouveauté avec le mandat de trump
c'est que la presse la presse d'un tissu
institutionnel dont on connaît par
exemple les penchants plutôt démocrate
plutôt le gauche progressiste pour le
washington post ou le meilleur test mais
là ont pris vraiment fait et cause
pendant le mandat de trump ils ont
vraiment essayé à chaque fois de trac
être absolument non mais ça et ça depuis
depuis le lendemain des élections de
souvenez-vous depuis le lendemain le new
yorker le new york times et le
washington post ont véritablement fait
de leur ligne éditoriale une attaque en
règle de trump depuis le début souvenez
vous en 2016
la question cette erreur s'ils étaient
insein si l'été s'il était fou à lier
vous souvenez à l'époque donc vraiment
ils se sont engagés pour avoir une ligne
éditoriale très clivée et finalement
c'est ce qui a fait leur succès l'autre
l'autre accusation c'est que on disait à
peu près de 80% des journalistes parce
que les états unis votre bail dunn et
sont accusés d' occulter ou minorés des
soupçons de corruption du fils de joe
biden oui alors ça c'est ça c'est là
c'est la question qui a été soulevée par
les les sénateurs républicains lors de
la dernière audition des patrons des
réseaux sociaux puisque le washington le
new york post pardon avait révélé une
information sur le fils de joe biden et
ça avait été censurée sur twitter
d'accord et donc les sénateurs
républicains qui avaient jack dorsey en
face lui ont demandé mais pourquoi est
ce que vous êtes censuré et lui d'une
manière assez
il fallait voir cette audition il a une
grande barbe on a l'impression que c'est
raspoutine maintenant 2 c'est pas très
grave on va arrêter ça ils ont qu à se
reconnecter et comme ça ils pourront
tweets et on va continuer de suivre
cette conversation avec vous en gerrans
mais puisque vous parlez de raspoutine
on va aller à moscou justement retrouver
notre correspondant à la barre lui et
à la barre lui et qui est également
ancien correspondant diplomatique et
militaire du figaro alors à la avant de
parler de votre regard en tant que
correspondant à moscou
quel regard vous qui me regardent qu'ils
observaient depuis longtemps ces
élections américaines
je ne sais pas si vous m'entendez
remporté l'élection a coûté ce qu'il
faut noter ici c'est que cette élection
américaine est bien plus présente dans
les médias et dans les préoccupations
des gens certes les grands journaux
depuis cette nuit font des fils
d'informations oh là l'une de leurs
sites internet
il ya des émissions spéciales sur les
grandes chaînes fédérales des visions
enfin on peut pas dire que cette
élection passionne les gens aiment bien
loin et il est prévu que les
préoccupations aussi sont d'ailleurs
liés aux grands navires us dont les
chiffres sont certainement beaucoup plus
élevés que ceux qui nous sont annoncés
c'est la baisse du niveau de vie puis
c'est les crises qui entoure ce grand
pays des crises dans l'étranger proche
donc l'élection américaine et les
lointaines et on n'est plus à l'époque
où comment dire la marche du monde se
décider dans la confrontation dans le
regard entre ces deux puissances
on en est on en est loin cela dit ce
matin je pense que même si a pas encore
eu de réaction officielle
le sentiment qui domine c'est celui d'un
soulagement soulagement de voir que la
vague démocrate n'a pas eu lieu car on
le sait et c'est une petite musique et
quand même qu'elle dédie astier ces
dernières semaines à moscou
votre app parce qu'on vote trump vous
disiez à l'instant halak
il ya d'autres enjeux
polarise l'attention et qui focalise
l'attention des russes
le coc vite bien entendu comme vous vous
en parler est ce qu'on peut dire que là
justement il n'ya pas il n'y a pas un
match en tout cas une course et une
concurrence un affrontement avec les
états unis sur cette question du coc
vide pour trouver justement le fameux
être le premier pour trouver le fameux
vaccin anti co-lead c'était poutine qui
parlait d'un vaccin qui s'appellerait
spoutnik à écouter les raisons le les
informations y aller la principale
information qui distille et si chaque
jour de façon ludique bhl c'est le futur
bassin et même les futurs d'axa dont il
n'y a pas un jour qui passe sans qu'on
nous annonce que la production et lancer
que le rallume de vaccination
généralisée incessamment sous peu
d'abord on a dit à la fin de l'année
puis ça a été embouti un peu mais c'est
effectivement une course au vaccin
les etats-unis ne sont pas dans cette
affaire explicitement nommées mais les
guerres qu'ils sont dans la ligne de
mire
et comme à l'époque où la conquête de
l'espace et un 10 peut le permettre mais
la compétition entre sept pays
c'est désormais le vaccin qui a pris
cette place et qui mobilise toutes les
tous les efforts scientifique ici si joe
biden est finalement élu ce qui entre
les caps et peut-être tout à fait
possible voire probable puisque pour
l'instant il est donné en tête
qu'est ce qui se passe à moscou qu'est
ce que l'on craint coûté d'alors nous
faut dire que
[Musique]
les observateurs une politologue tout ce
qu'on peut leur duvet termine toujours
par dumas finalement ça n'a pas ça va
pas changer l'enjeu le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe sergueï lavrov
gr10 elle est de toute façon nous allons
travailler avec nos bons ça c'est du
langage diplomatique
et il ajoutait mais nous n'avons pas
d'espérance trop haute
car le contexte des relations entre les
états unis leur vie s'ils sont très
dégradées ce qui peut changer mais en
moins et ce qui fait aussi que moscou a
quand même une forte prédilection pour
c'est que un réinvestissement des états
unis dans tous ces terrains
géopolitiques qui ont été délaissés par
washington depuis que l'homme de
l'america first est à la maison blanche
la conséquence de ça ça serait une
moindre
je dirais facilité ou les ans de moscou
a joué sur ses terrains où elle s'est
affirmée sans résultats définitifs ce
soit en libye
ce soit moyen-orient mais malgré tout le
l'absence des etats-unis de l'europe à
halen reviendrai certainement davantage
vers les européens
tout ça fait le jeu de fait le jeu de
aussi alors à là on va terminer cette
conversation parce qu'apparemment donald
trump est en train d'arriver sur le
pupitre qui lui étaient dressés à la
maison blanche on va l'écouter le temps
qu'il arrive peut-être une toute
dernière question est ce qu est ce qu'en
russie on parle d affaires de corruption
du fils de joe biden écoutez
on en a parlé mais je dois dire que
cette rencontre coût de toutes ces
affaires qui avaient émaillé à la merci
j'ai pardon je vais je vais en gérons
plus que je n'hésite pas à revenir vers
vous mais pour l'instant on va à
washington ont chuté donald trump
[Applaudissements]
merci j'avais fait une conférence de
presse au sitar merci beaucoup de
millions de personnes qui ont voté pour
nous ce soir
malheureusement un groupe de personnes
en train d'essayer de priver de leurs
droits
cet autre groupe de personnes ça ne nous
demandez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se prépare à faire une grosse fête
parce qu'on est entrain de toute la nuit
résultat ce soir ont été phénoménaux et
on se prépare
je veux dire clairement on était prêt à
sortir du bois et à faire la fête
de fait après une merveilleuse jeu le
soir et les votes extraordinaire les
citoyens de ce pays qui sont allés aux
urnes en homme propre corps et genesis a
eu d'abord prévu que la venue de bruce
march le plus grand destin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
117 111 voix pour ni un peu tous ceux
qui restent à dépouiller ne nous
rattraperont jamais de la même façon
nous avons remporté la caroline du nord
1,4 pour cent de plus samedi dix mille
votes et une ligne elle reste quelques
sources en rade à dépouiller donc ils ne
peuvent pas nous rattraper puis par
ailleurs si vous regardez l'arizona
quelqu'un a déclaré que possible en tout
cas il ya eu beaucoup de voix et il
reste beaucoup de voix qu'on peut avoir
parce que on est en train d'arriver sur
le dépouillement du territoire troc dit
pas si c'est une bonne expression qu'a
dit ortiz qui m'aime bien et donc je
trouve que ça des tromperait monsieur
que j'ai entendu à la télé ce soir
qu'ils écrivent que c'est qu'il est
assez peu probable peu probable mais
qu'est ce que c'est
et puis d'ailleurs nous n'avons même pas
besoin si on avait eu l'arizona serait
été formidable la farce a besoin et
d'ailleurs il est possible c'est
possible même des changements sur x dont
là ils sont la soirée mais enfin on voit
les chiffres les derniers chiffres bons
semblerait évidemment ça soit encore
dans la balance mais encore plus
important
c'est important
6 688 voix d'écart donc hors des très
très très très loin
c'est pas comme si on pouvait dire
hausse est très proche on ne sait pas
exactement et avec le nombre de voix
assez faible qui restent à dépouiller il
sera impossible pour eux de nous
rattraper
et puis d'ailleurs on va aller vers on
va aller vers le dépouillement de
parties de la pennsylvanie où on aime
bien notre président donc voilà ça se
présente bien gagner au michigan
michigan j'ai dit waouh quand j'ai vu
les résultats jeudi voir c'est des
chiffres impressionnants 300 une folle
et 55% des voix ont déjà été dès juillet
est on en train de gagner risque en
scène et on n'a pas besoin de tous ses
états on en a même pas besoin parce que
si vous ajoutez le lob de classe qui n'a
pas encore été ajoutées les wade compte
j'ai parlé avec les merveilleux
gouverneur du texas
il m'a dit félicitations il m'a appelé
pour me fondre à tulle et pour me
féliciter pour le texas un jeu passif au
sûr qu'ils aient toutes avaient fini le
décompte mais enfin c'est c'est
irrattrapable pour le pour les
démocrates en tout cas il m'a félicité
et m'a dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
j'ai jamais rien vu de semblable
et vous savez quoi c'est vrai on n'a
jamais vu quelque chose de semblable
80 % du vote nous gagnons donc le
michigan donc si vous prenez ces états
là et les autres je veux dire regardez
je veux dire c'est une soirée
extraordinaire
regardez tous ces états que nous avons
remporté ce soir
et puis vous regardez surtout les mêmes
marges c'est pas comme si on avait douze
voix d'écart et qu'il nous restait 60 70
votes à dépouiller
on a gagné dans tous ses états et d'un
seul coup on nous dit c'est cette
élection non c'est pas terrible ça va
pas marcher ça va pas passer alors on
leur pose la question que se passe-t-il
et nous disons ce que s'est il passé en
fait ils savent qu'il va gagner
santes et ils disent on va aller le nom
les tribunaux et ça je l'avais prévu dès
le début je l'avais dit qu'ils allaient
envoyer des dizaines de milliers de
bulletins de vote qu'ils gagnent ou
qu'ils ne gagnent pas ils ont bien
l'intention de nous poursuivre en
justice
donc je reprends cet égard la floride et
marion succès le texas je voulais dit
l'ohio son geste un peu loyaux un grand
des tarnais à merveilleux
[Applaudissements]
quatre cent mille vols écart 8 % d'écart
caroline du nord là encore un gros
succès et nous avons gagné 2,76
quasiment plus rien dépouillé et puis
d'un seul coup tout s'arrête
c'est une fronde dont le public
américain dont les américains sont la
victime extrêmement embarrassant pour
damas car nous étions prêts à gagner
cette élection
et très franchement que nous avons
connus cette élection
notre lutte
à ce stade et de veiller à l'intégrité
pour le bien des états unis c'est un
moment très important c'est une fraude
majeure de notre pays
nous voulons que la loi que le droit
soit utilisé à bon escient
nous allons donc c'est saisir la cour
suprême
nous voulons que les votes s'arrête vous
pas qu'on retrouve d'un seul coup des
bulletins de vote à 4 heures du matin
c'est que soit le bourg et les lie dans
le home
c'est très triste est vraiment très
triste à mort ça m'attriste énormément
nous allons gagner d'ailleurs et puis
mon point de vue j'ai l'impression qu'on
a déjà gagné donc voilà je ne me reste
qu'à vous remarqué
et puis je remercie tous ceux qui l'ont
soutenu tous ceux aux états unis qui ont
travaillé avec nous monsieur le vice
président je vous propose de dire
quelques mots simulé
[Applaudissements]
le président est une société plus de 60
millions d'américains qui ont déjà
déposé leur bulletin dans l'urne
souhaitant qu'il y ait quatre années de
plus de mandat donald trump et plus nous
allons regarder ce qui se passe dessous
de très près le droit de vote est au
coeur de notre démocratie depuis la
fondation des états unis nous allons
protéger l'intégrité du vote
je crois vraiment de tout mon coeur
extraordinaire marge on vous parliez
monsieur le président que vous avez
inspiré dans les états dont vous nous
parlez avec ce slogan domec merkel gagne
je crois vraiment comme vous que nous
sommes sur la voie de la victoire et que
nous rendrons sa puissance sa gloire aux
états unis mais marquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez pu suivre donc
en direct pardon pour les petits soucis
qu'on a eu et merci à travail de notre
équipe qui a permis de résoudre tout ça
en direct en temps réel en flux tendu le
président des états unis donald trump
donc qui revendique sa victoire et qui
annonce que la cour suprême et saisi un
commentaire peut-être sur tout ce qui a
été dit par le président américain en
gerrans et puis du poids du qui est le
vôtre c'est sur la façon dont l' annonce
la communication de cette décision est
de 7,2 cette vision entre les cas des
élections et du résultat
promue par le président américain est
livrée cette séquence est très
instructive et en a vu il ya un vers 7h
heure française une heure du matin heure
américaine joe biden prendre la parole
très vite en disant nous sommes
confiants nous allons gagner
on avait l'impression que c'était un peu
dans la précipitation et puis là
aujourd'hui de 1h30 plus tard trump
prend la parole dit très calmement il
égrène les résultats il dit très
calmement qu'il a gagné il dit nous
avons gagné cette élection et c'est là
ce que je voulais vous dire c'était il
peut dire ça sur une tribune il peut
dire ça relayées sur les télévisions
les radios il ne peut pas dire ça
aujourd'hui en ce moment sur les réseaux
sociaux
et ça c'est un moment très particulier
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont pris la parole
aussi tard dans la nuit il me l'a dit
c'est la première fois que je fais une
conférence de presse aussi tardive il
est 2h30 du matin à la main mais là ils
pouvaient s'exprimer librement et être
repris par tous et imposer l'idée qu'ils
avaient gagné une peut-être une toute
dernière question celle déposée par un
internaute qui nous dit est ce que par
exemple au niveau des médias français
qui sont très favorables en tous les cas
plus tôt à trump en tout cas les gens
les français abandonnent pardon il n'y a
pas eu justement une faillite un peu du
wishful thinking dans dance est dans
cette élection c'est la deuxième
faillite un 2016-2020 wishful thinking
hier soir on entendait encore à peu près
sur rampe ses désirs pour des réalités
voilà on voulait tous les courants les
médias français que c'était que c'était
quasiment plié qu'il fallait faire très
attention
on répétait en boucle qu'il y avait 90%
de chances que joe biden gagne c'est
toujours la même difficulté
c'est à dire un prisme et pourtant
pourtant beaucoup sur aller sur le
terrain et plus sur les terrains
beaucoup beaucoup des médias français
plus qu'en 2016 en 2007 on avait oublié
l'amérique profonde je pas si vous vous
souvenez personne n'avait été dans la la
ceinture de rouille comme comme on dit
dans les dents les étapes profond là est
beaucoup de journalistes français ils
sont allés ils ont regardé
ils ont donné la parole à tout le monde
mais ils ont continué à percer persuadé
que
joe biden avait gagné ce qui est encore
possible personne ne le sait oui ça
donne alors il ya plusieurs chiffres on
vient d'en donner vous en avez d'autres
sur le site du figaro même foxnews un
qui est favorable dont quatre hommes
donnent une avance en ce moment à joe
biden mais 238 gans d'électeurs au tour
2 213 pour donald trump
on est pas encore on n'a pas encore
dépassé le stade des 270 un grand
électeur peut-être une question encore
charlotte
on a la chance d'avoir en guérand en
plateau sur effectivement les la façon
peut-être dont la russie traite et les
médias russes traite ce matin cette
élection américaine finalement c'est
assez mezzo voce oui parce qu'ils font
très très attention à la barre et nous
nous dira mieux mais on souvenez vous on
les a accusés d'avoir interféré dans les
élections en 2016 et ça a été ça a été
traîné comme un boulet pendant trump
pendant quatre ans là ils se ils font
très attention de l'interféron
aucunement les gaffes à s'y tromper
c'est lui justement si en plus trump est
censurée de facto sur twitter est ce
qu'ils peuvent craindre ce que on voit
quand même plus ou moins poindre un
démantèlement comme on a vu dans
l'histoire économique américaine non non
non non cela aussi on accuse les gaffes
à d'être pro démocrates mais les pires
ennemis des gaffes a cédé démocrates
c'est la gauche des démocrates avec
elizabeth warren qui voulait et qui
voulait imposer l'idée d'un
démantèlement
les républicains ne sont pas sur cette
ligne du moins pas encore sur cette
ligne du démantèlement ils sont
davantage sur la ligne de la régulation
et de la fin de la section de 130
merci beaucoup en gerrans et merci
d'être passé sur le plateau du figaro
bien sûr on recommande sur l'édition
papier du figaro
la dernière page les dernières pages du
figaro économie que vous dirigez et bien
sûr le récit tout le récit de cette
campagne vu justement sous l'angle des
médias et de la communication
merci encore à bientôt ainsi on file
tout de suite à berlin en direct à
berlin avec notre correspondant
pierre avril bonjour pierre bonjour
merci d'être en direct avec nous pour
l'instant évidemment nous n'avons pas le
nom du vainqueur même si comme vous
l'avez entendu donald trump vient
d'intervenir en direct et il revendique
pour l'instant sa victoire joe biden un
peu plus tôt avait lui même dit que les
choses étaient bien engagées pour lui
cependant comment serait perçu un second
mandat de donald trump par berlin bâle
c'est à dire que les choses se sont mal
passées pendant quatre ans de trump d
c'est vrai que le gouvernement allemand
ne verrait pas d'abo deuil second mandat
de trump vu la teneur du premier donc
c'est vrai que le scénario espéré à
berlin majoritairement sans qu'il soit
évident beau exprimer à haute voix
serait évidemment une victoire du
démocrate joe biden à 30 puisque par
droit non je dis simplement que il y a
eu des décès vers conflit entre
l'administration américaine et le
gouvernement allemand pas vos quatre ans
ça allait des restrictions commerciales
le fait que les etats-unis reprochent à
l'allemagne de ne pas payer suffisamment
au budget de temps les conflits
concernant le gaz le gazoduc north
stream
et puis la décision américaine de ne
retirer ses troupes d'allemagne tout ça
a créé des sources terrible de conflit
entre les deux capitales et de ce point
de vue là il est clair que l'allemagne
ne verrait pas d'abord aller sur de
donald trump traitement des relations
qui ont uni les états unis à l'allemagne
ces quatre dernières années
oui les lions étaient on peut dire
exécrable donald rock 10
les allemands sont très mauvais c'est ce
qu'il disait au début de 200 mamba
les allemands sont venus à se demander
s'il fallait pas qu'ils gèrent eux mêmes
leur propre sécurité c'est à dire il en
venait à se demander si finalement il
est berlin pourrait vraiment compter sur
les américains pour pour assurer leur
propre sécurité
cette sécurité elle est active depuis
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'est quand même un pilier
sur lequel sont toujours appuyés les
allemands trump a semblé la remettre en
cause et ça c'est une interrogation
existentielle quasiment chez les
allemands et un second mandat trompe
signifierait probablement un délitement
supplémentaire dans cette danse est
appuyé finalement sécuritaire que là que
là que là que les états unis ont
toujours apporté à l'allemagne donald
trump et celle d'angela merkel ces
dernières années les relations étaient
n'étaient pas bonnes les relations entre
les neuf n'étaient pas bonnes
la chancelière s'est toujours s'est
toujours gardé de critiquer publiquement
évidemment son son interlocuteur mais on
a cru effectivement sentir des moments
de tension d'exaspération une preuve en
est c'est que hier ça concernait pas
directement la chancellerie mais on a
entendu le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
social-démocrate aiko basse qui a appelé
à nous un new deal un nouveau deal à
nouvel accord avec les etats-unis ce qui
voulait dire en creux que qu'un second
mandat de troc ne ne pourrait pas fallu
si j'étais un new deal et même le
ministre également social-démocrate des
finances a espéré bouin division et plus
d'harmonie dans la société américaine
autant de critiques en creux de de ce
qu'est de ce que sont les états unis de
ce qu'est aujourd'hui la société
américaine donc si vous voulez le fait
que de hauts responsables du
gouvernement face de deux commentaires
pareils à la veille des élections
montrent qu'ils avaient quand même
montre qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
désillusions c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
du côté du côté allemand en restant dans
cette hypothèse que donald trump
remporte l'élection aux états unis si on
ouvre plus largement aux rapports des
états unis avec l'europe quel avenir on
peut envisager pour pour l'europe dans
les 4 prochaines années
les allemands souhaitent je souhaiterais
que l'europe s'engage davantage et et
montrent un front uni par rapport aux
états unis que l'europe
puisse avoir une voix sur des conflits
notamment sur lequel est très peu
présente notamment les conflits liés aux
relations entre le entre les états unis
à la chine elle voudrait être davantage
présente en chine l'allemagne par
l'intermédiaire de l'union européenne
c'est vrai que l'allemagne se verrait
bien une espèce de reconquête
diplomatique de l'europe face aux états
unis encore faut-il que que que cette
cette main tendue si elle devait se
tendre effectivement soit soit prise du
côté américain et on imagine mal s'ils
trompent et élus qui le bruissement
prennent 7 7 m'a tendu que lui tendrais
les allemands et éventuellement l'union
européenne
si on vous suit bien et qu'on résume aux
propos pierre avril c'est dans le cadre
d'une victoire la victoire de joe biden
si elle arrivait
elle serait une bien meilleure nouvelle
pour l'allemagne elle serait une bien
meilleure nouvelle parce qu'elle
apporterait davantage de stabilité
et disons de confiance on on ne fait pas
des visions sur bail donne on sait que
brydon et protectionniste qui serait pas
forcément très conciliants concernant le
problème du libre commerce qui comme une
sujet central aux états unis ou en
allemagne qui veut vendre des voitures
par exemple les états unis on sait que
que les jo byden ou aux états unis
certainement défendrait des intérêts de
l'industrie américaine mais on crédite
quand même
joe biden de la volonté de trouver des
désaccords dans le cas des institutions
multilatérales dans le cadre de l'om
s'est par exemple dans le cadre de l'onu
et ça c'est très important le fait que
joe biden puis s'inscrire dans une
démarche de renégociation de
conciliation et ne peut ne pratique pas
comme donald trump l'a fait cette
politique de la chaise vide ou en tout
cas du retrait comme ça a été fait
vis-à-vis de lohan ses vis-à-vis de la
corde paris sur le climat et vis-à-vis
du de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
les allemands vol que les états unis
reviennent sur la scène internationale
est souvent considéré comme un
partenaire de négociation avec que l'on
puisse vraiment discuter et négocier
merci beaucoup pire avril pour ses
éclairages
on vous retrouve évidemment sur les
pages du figaro et sur le site
lefigaro.fr
merci encore d'avoir été en direct avec
nous pour cette matinale américaine
vincent merci beaucoup pierre et on est
heureux d'accueillir isabelle lasserre
bonjour
vous suivez des questions diplomatiques
et de relations internationales au
service international du figaro nous
allons gagner c'est ce qu'a déclaré joe
biden donc ce matin très tôt donald
trump lui-même revendique avoir gagné
l'élection et annonce saisir la cour
suprême pour l'instant 238 grands
électeurs selon foxnews donc plutôt
favorable à de ne pas plutôt favorable
de notre 238 grands électeurs à joe
biden 230 à donald trump on n'a pas
encore donné le décompte de nationale 2
voies on sait que ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance dans le scrutin américain
mais pour l'instant joe biden
effectivement à une légère avance
vance 49,8 devant donald trump 48,6 il
reste encore et on va compter un deux
trois quatre cinq voire six est taclé
encore qu'ils doivent donner les
résultats ça risque d'être long il faut
impérativement que donald trump les les
remporte s'il veut avoir une chance de
gagner l'élection
à cet instant là et on va un petit peu
dur et sur le rhin parti qu'est ce que
quel est votre regard quel est votre
qu'est ce que vous dites
isabelle lasserre mais moi je me dis que
il se passe quand même un petit peu ce
qu'on redoutait que c'est finalement
assez assez logique en france et en
europe on a tendance à considérer que
certains débordements de trump certaines
déclarations allaient forcément le faire
perdre je prends je prends je prends
juste deux exemples
je prends le moment où trump se vante à
la télé en disant qu'il n'a pas payé
d'impôts ici en france la réaction celle
d'hier l'aï dégringole dans les sondages
a trop de risques
c'est pas possible mais pas du tout dans
l'électorat de trump ne pas payer ses
impôts contourner l'état
c'est super c'est le cow boys et le
white gaye s'est il fait exactement ce
qu'il faut faire dans la deuxième chose
c'est le coronavirus et on s'est dit ok
il est allé à l'hôpital ça va le faire
dégringoler
mais pas du tout à l'arrivée il encore
plus jeunes qu'avant il a une énergie
qui est dix fois celle de joe biden et
il a effectivement vaincu le coronavirus
donc tout ça ça joue en faveur de trempe
tout c'est tout c'est en fait c'est tout
c'est fait toutes ces déclarations dont
on pensait en france qu'elle allait
émoussé son électorat qui n'a pas bougé
qui tient absolument fermement et qui
prouve une fois encore que le train de
peace mme est vraiment un phénomène de
fond qui peut d'une part la la la
division absolument extrême de
l'amérique mais mais mais mais qui
prouve que que des 30 n'est pas du tout
un accident de l'histoire est que le
tram peace man plus va perdurer avec ou
sans trump parce que les résultats sont
extrêmement serrés
les résultats sont extrêmement serrés on
continue à les suivre vous restez avec
nous sur figaro live et sur le site du
figaro on vous donne toutes les
éclairages toutes les informations tous
les derniers chiffres avec isabelle
jeanne rien qu'on revienne sur un
certain nombre de vos spécialités
vous avez écrit un très bon livre qu'on
recommande chez jean claude lattès qui
s'appelle le réveil des armées ssa parle
de la france l'armée américaine en tous
les cas le haut commandement américain a
fait on peut dire littéralement la
guerre à trump qui le lui a bien rendu
pourquoi et est ce que ça peut changer
en cas de victoire de donald trump
vous voulez dire les rapports entre
l'armée américaine le haut commandement
américain et donald trump
écoutez je ne pense pas il faut déjà
noter que si les relations de la france
avec la maison blanche
ce sont un petit peu dégradée au fil du
monde à trump elles sont toujours rester
absolument parfaite avec tout l'appareil
militaire c'est-à-dire qui a toujours
que cette connexion et ça s'est toujours
très bien passé ça risque de ne pas
changer parce que d'abord il va y avoir
des coupes budgétaires dans l'armée
américaine comme d'ailleurs dans toutes
les armées du monde due aux conséquences
économiques de
de la crise sanitaire et la deuxième
raison c'est que le programme de trump
va se poursuivre qui est un retrait des
opérations militaires au moyen-orient
c'est le premier en asie premier
président depuis carter qui n'a pas
déclenché de guerre mais oui mais
c'était dans son programme donald trump
a tenu quand même pas mal de ses
promesses c'est le premier effectivement
qui n'est pas de déclencher de guerre
c'est ce que dit excusez moi josiane
vais je suis sûr qu'ils nous sont
souvent sur le figaro sur youtube sur la
chaîne filles relève youtube elle nous
dit effectivement trump en quatre ans 0
guerre en quatre ans 0 guerre le
processus de retrait des affaires du
monde et d intervention extérieure n'a
pas été inventé par donald trump il a
été inventé par barack obama c'est
barack obama qui a commencé et en fait
donald trump n'a fait que poursuivre la
politique de barack obama
avec un peu plus de deux manières un peu
plus chaotique et est un peu plus
violentes et il a tenu une promesse que
n'avait pas tenu et aux bahamas et l
autre d'afghanistan et il a tenu une
promesse que n'avait pas tenu obama lé
retrait de l'afghanistan
maintenant les années qui viennent nous
diront si ça va durer
la décision risque de revenir tel un bon
rang parce qu'en fait il à redonner les
clés
enfin il apparent de lewy à redonner les
clés aux talibans dans le pays donc plus
de 20 ans d'intervention militaire
des centaines de millions de dollars
dépensés pour vaincre les talibans et al
qaïda et à l'arrivée on a les talibans
qui s'apprête à prendre
kaboul et al-qaïda toujours là et l'état
islamique qui s'est développée belle
réussite et on espère que les celles
liées aux talibans pour combattre al
qaïda
le
vous disiez une trame finalement c'est
inscrit dans le petit peu comme dans
l'héritage d'obama sur ces plans là sept
internautes du figaro nous demande si il
ne s'inscrit pas dans la droite ligne
d'un ancien président celle de jackson
celui ci étant lui-même populiste en bas
il l'était moins mais de toute façon le
l'amérique a toujours alterné les
périodes de d'isolationnisme et
d'interventionnisme c1 c'est un
phénomène c'est un phénomène de balance
donc c'est certain mais là ça me paraît
plus profond parce que l'amérique a
vraiment changé elle est devenue moins
européenne notamment parce que les
populations latino afro américaines sont
plus nombreuses et elles s'éloignent de
l'europe et c'est la première fois qu'on
voit je crois dans deux mandats
successifs donc là je mets barack obama
et donald trump
ce retrait profond et qui va se
poursuivre parce que si joe biden réélu
ok ce sera une bonne nouvelle pour
l'europe et pour la france parce que les
relations vont redevenir normales pas
s'y fier parce que il va renouer avec
les habitudes les traditions du
multilatéralisme et revenir dans
certains accords internationaux mais sur
le fond la politique de dubaï donnait
une mauvaise nouvelle pour l'europe
c'est à dire que le retrait américain du
moyen-orient et d'europe va se
poursuivre aujourd'hui l'obsession des
états unis c'est la chine c'est
l'affirmation de la chine s'était pas le
cas sous jackson et c'est de toute façon
que les présidents démocrates ou
républicains n'ont qu'un mot à la tête
et se trouve donc en mots à la bouche
c'est se tourner vers un pivot asiatique
est vraiment le coeur de la politique
étrangère américaine et c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'europe y sous
trump avait pour la première fois eu des
frémissements de
de puissance c'est-à-dire quand on se
disait ok il va falloir enfin prendre
notre défense en main ça commençait ça a
commencé un petit peu à prendre une
présidence by donne pour ça risque
d'être catastrophique c'est à dire que à
nouveau tous les pays qui étaient
réticents et je pense à l'allemagne le
le correspondant pierre avril a
parfaitement illustré
on peut tout à fait craindre que
l'allemagne se jette dans l'est dans les
bras de joe biden est elle qui est si
les dix ans tu as utilisé sa puissance
militaire alors les allemands ne sont
pas naïfs mais il y aura cette tentation
de revenir sous le parapluie militaire
américain avec un président qui nous
ressemble qui est normal mesurerait qui
a beaucoup d'expérience
voilà ce sera sans doute pas le cas et
ce sera sans doute une mauvaise nouvelle
pour l'europe
une autre question justement corrélative
à celle là qu elle est une internaute du
fida à l'internaute également du figaro
qui demande la victoire de trappes ne
serait-elle pas une bonne nouvelle dans
ce cas là pour erdogan dans la mesure où
trump se désengage de l'europe
abbas est une excellente nouvelle pour
erdogan est comme ça quelques quelques
présidents sur dans la dans le monde qui
sont qui seront ravis braire dogan
netanyahu
le président nord-coréen pour erdogan
bien sûr parce que erdogan
poutine oui c'est plus est plus ambigu
pour vladimir poutine parce que si
donald trump a toujours ménagé vladimir
poutine
ce n'est pas le cas de du congrès 1 et 2
et 2 et du sénat en fait il ya une
espèce de il ya quand même une réticence
russes aux états unis qui est qui et
bipartisane qui est partagé par les
républicains et par les démocrates
mais erdogan bien sûr erdogan a été l'un
des premiers gagnants de cette période
trump à ce que le retrait américain du
moyen-orient lui a permis de prendre
cette autoroute qui qui qui menait vers
le retour de la puissance turque et néo
ottomane dans toute la région donc c'est
une très bonne nouvelle parce qu'il va
pouvoir continuer à s'enfoncer dans dans
tous ces pays
il est 8 heures 55 donc sur figaro live
et pour l'instant on ne connaît toujours
pas le nom du gagnant entre joe biden et
donald trump tous les deux revendiquent
la victoire joe biden pense qu'il va
l'obtenir de notre un pli de la déjà
revendiqué il a saisi la cour suprême
pour l'instant aucun des deux candidats
n'a recueilli suffisamment de grands
électeurs vous voyez en ce moment donc
la jauge que l'on vous montre sur le
site du figaro 225 grands électeurs pour
joe biden 213 pour donald trump
il en faut 270 au niveau national pour
l'instant c'est plutôt une légère avance
en faveur de joe biden je reviens sur ce
que on
le début de notre conversation isabelle
sur la l'affrontement qui a eu entre le
haut commandement militaire américain et
le système de et le la direction de la
sécurité américaine et les grands
responsables et aux responsables de
sécurité américaine et la maison blanche
et donald trump est ce que dans ce
combat traité qui quand même très
violent puisque on a eu quand même des
livres en plus qui sont sortis des
fuites dont on pense qu'elles ont été
orchestrés quand même par les services
de renseignement est ce que c'est le
résultat justement de la politique de
désengagement militaire de donald trump
et de la réduction budgétaire qui
finalement est la conséquence de ces
désengagements c'est ça ça plus une
autre chose qu'une question de personne
et de personnalités de manière de
gouverner c'est à dire que les
établissements de militaires et c'est le
cas dans tous les pays mais donc surtout
aux états unis
ce sont des chefs militaires et des
responsables militaires sont des gens
qui raisonnent dans le temps long
l'armée est une c'est le temps long les
équipements ont mes 30 ans à l'échangé
30 ans allait construire les stratégies
elle se penche sur de longues années
parce qu'on ne gagne pas une guerre en
une semaine et donald trump est
quelqu'un qui gouverne
on a l'impression qu'ils gouvernent dans
le temps court c'est à dire qu'ils
changent de décision il est imprévisible
et il prend complètement rebrousse poil
l'état major des armées sur des
décisions qui sont très graves par
exemple je sais qu'ils n'ont guère
apprécié la manière dont il a géré le
sujet de la corée du nord d'un point de
vue militaire ce qu'il a fait est
totalement aberrant c'est à dire que les
américains veulent empêcher que un
dictateur se dote de la bombe nucléaire
et à l'arrivée on le légitime et on a on
a un pays qui est nucléarisé et c'est la
même chose pour l'iran les militaires
mais comme les diplomates et la maison
blanche avait pour but que l'iran ne se
dote pas de la bombe nucléaire
la politique de donald trump à l'arrivée
non seulement à renforcer les
conservateurs iraniens
mais pendant cette présidence trump le
programme nucléaire iranien est reparti
alors justement on va en reparler
avec vous cette question peut être quand
même de sept internautes du figaro qui
de 10 souvenez-vous de petraeus
mcchrystal sous obama en particulier
david petraeus qui était quand même
l'une des grandes figures de la guerre
américaine en irak de la
contre-insurrection en irak inspiré de
penseurs français
petraeus avait été limogé par obama mais
petraeus a soutenu que je baille donne
dans cette élection
oui mais
oui comme comme la plupart des
responsables
militaires dont km pour la version wii
il ya une profonde aversion c'est
complètement complètement antinomique la
la la stratégie militaire là la
prospective s'accordent extrêmement mal
avec la manière de gouverner de donald
trump
quelles conséquences peut avoir une
victoire de joe biden sur la corde paris
sur l'accord iranien les relations avec
la france les relations avec emmanuel
macron en cas de victoire de trump ou de
bail donne
on va voir ça dans un instant avec
isabelle lasserre mais d'abord peut-être
charlotte voisine encore neuf à 8h59
nouveaux résultats résultat très
important puisque on apprend que
l'arizona est remporté par baï donne
donc c'est un premier revers pour donald
trump
on en parle tout de suite avec renault
fier en direct depuis sa son studio
nous sommes deux filiales à new zone de
figaro live pour nous donner les
dernières dernières infos concernant les
résultats selon les états oui y'en a des
biens venus encore dans mon studio
en tout cas vous vous l'avez suivi sur
figaro live c'était aux alentours de
8h15 l'interview par dont l'intervention
de donald trump pendant une dizaine de
minutes le président américain qui a
remercié ses soutiens qui s'est lui-même
étonné de certains résultats provisoires
dans certains états qu'il pensait perdre
mais qui évitait soigneusement de
proclamer sa victoire jusqu'à la
dernière minute en fait où il a déclaré
en ce qui me concerne nous avons déjà
gagné cette élection
il poursuit notre but est maintenant de
garantir l'intégrité de cette victoire
nous irons la cour suprême pour nous
assurer qu'aucun vote ne sera désormais
comptés alors pour donner un peu de
contexte
le président américain qui critique une
nouvelle fois le mode de scrutin de
certains états qui autorise le
dépouillement des votes
après le 3 novembre on le rappelle à
chaque état américain est libre
d'organiser les règles électorales comme
il le souhaite en tout cas à 9 heures on
ne peut pas affirmer que donald trump a
effectivement gagné cette élection ni
joe biden c'est le premier des trois
enseignements de cette matinée
électorale donald trump vous le voyez on
est à 213 grands électeurs joe biden en
est à 225 pour vous donner une idée
hillary clinton
on avait obtenu 227 en 2016 d
bulletins n'ont pas encore été
dépouillés et dans certains comtés on
prévient même qu'il faudra déjà
plusieurs heures supplémentaires
plusieurs jours supplémentaires
peut-être pour tous les comptabiliser le
deuxième enseignement il ne fait
vraiment pas bon être sondeurs américain
depuis quatre ans certains instituts ont
peut-être mettre la clé sous la porte
aujourd'hui deuxième revers de suite
et peu importe le vainqueur de
l'élection ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que vraiment dans de nombreuses
élections qui était annoncé comme serré
par des instituts de sondage
les résultats ne l'ont pas été du tout
exemple au texas qui est toujours
républicain et trump a ici une avance de
plus de six points également le cas dans
l'ohio a annoncé comme serré mais en
fait trump a eu huit points d'avance et
dans l'iowa
donald trump avait sept points d'avance
le thermomètre politiques qui sont qui
semble donc cassé aux états unis le
troisième enseignement enfin c'est que
la carte électorale finalement n'a pas
beaucoup bougé depuis quatre ans à
l'heure où l'on se parle à par l'arizona
qui vient de basculer dans le camp
démocrate on vient de le dire
aucun état gagné par 2016 en donald
trump n'a été perdu à l'heure où on se
parle alors cela peut changer mais à
l'heure où on se parle
aucun état n'a été perdu et pourtant
dans certains états il avait créé
véritablement la surprise le pari
démocrate d'avoir voulu de faire de
cette élection un référendum en titre up
est aujourd'hui un pari perdu ils
espéraient un raz-de-marée bleus ils
n'ont eu qu'une douche froide même si la
maison blanche n'est pas encore
complètement perdus à l'heure où on se
parle et vous avez gagné peut-être là la
palme de la punchline entre cette marée
bleue qui est devenue une douche froide
merci renaud vous restez avec nous on va
continuer quand même deux suivants sera
sans doute un point peut-être dans une
demi heure trois quarts d'heure pour
justement voir où l'on en est encore
parce que le décompte continuer on va
continuer à suivre ça on est avec
isabelle lasserre ont le voulu poser vos
questions toutes vos questions vous
savez isabelle lasserre s'est garé grand
reporter
ancienne correspondante de défense
aujourd'hui correspondant diplomatique
donc peut répondre à beaucoup de
questions peut-être une question de sept
internautes du figaro live quels sont
les projets de peu de politique
intérieure de trump en cas de victoire
j'avoue que je me pose la question mais
peut-être que les électeurs américains
se posent aussi la question
trump n'a n'a pas vraiment de programme
mais en ce qui concerne la politique
intérieure
c'est le même programme qui va se
poursuivre notamment au niveau fiscal
baisse des impôts etc par contre il
n'est pas très claire de ce qu'on ne
sait pas très bien ce qui va faire au
niveau de l'immigration parce que ça a
été en fait un de ses seins de cg c'est
qu'au niveau intérieur souvenez-vous
vincent du mur qu'il avait voulu
construire entre les etats-unis et le
mexique
il s'est trouvé complètement bloquée par
le congrès il n'a pas eu les fonds pour
le terminer et finalement il n'a pas
réussi à juguler l'immigration comme ils
entendaient le faire
on en parlait tout à l'heure sur les
conséquences que peut avoir donc soit
une seconde administration trump soit
une administration by dad
pour l'instant c'est by dane qui tient
la tête qui tient à la course en tête
donc mettons mettons nous dans
l'hypothèse où dubaï donne encore le
l'emportent dans ce cas là est ce que on
peut espérer que les accords de paris
que trump les accords de paris sur le
climat que trump mis à la poubelle
puisse finalement être être en tous les
cas que bynum les respecte il ya deux
choses qui sont quasi certaine et qui
figure noir et blanc dans les promesses
électorales de beille donne à ce niveau
là c'est retour dans l'accord de paris
sur le climat et l'autre chose c'est
retour dans le mc une autre montre là où
il ya une très grosse ambiguïté ces
retours ou non dans l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien le jcp haut à bail
donne ne l'a pas exclu mais il a dit je
reviendrai les etats-unis reviendront
si l'iran fait quelques concessions et
les concessions c'est revenir exactement
dans les termes de l'accord nucléaire
iranien et accepté de parler des autres
sujets qui posent problème c'est
notamment le programme balistique
iranien et les opérations de
déstabilisation menée par l'iran dans
tout le moyen-orient
et ça pour l'instant côté iranien il
n'en est pas question donc tous ceux qui
espèrent aujourd'hui une normalisation
et un une reprise de des affaires
diplomatiques sur la sphère de
de l'accord iranien et
peuvent je pense attendre encore
longtemps je remercie
pendant que de vous reposer la question
claudius qui dit qu'elle demande si elle
peut applaudir la résistance des
journalistes sur le plateau qui ne
prennent pas de pause effectivement vous
pouvez vous à plusieurs on est très
sensible en tous les cas à vous à vos
remarques et vous continuez claudius
parce que vous êtes là depuis le début
de la matinale non plus vous ne prenez
pas de pause et vous avez raison de
continuer puisque cette élection est
absolument palpitante
on ne connaît toujours pas le nom le
résultat du vainqueur et on voit quand
même une chose qui est intéressante
c'est que aucune
aucun institut de sondage ce matin
aucune chaîne au camp grands médias
américains en tous les cas d'après ce
que nous disent les dépêches d'agencé ne
pronostics de victoire et une annonce un
gagnant c'est même un changement par
rapport à 2000 où chaque média annoncés
annoncés sont vaincus ils font bien de
s'abstenir d'annoncer le vainqueur avant
que l'histoire soit terminée ça peut
pencher d'un côté comme de l'autre
l'expérience de 2016 a été vraiment
absolument traumatisante et en plus
enfin bon on aura peut-être le nom d'un
président demain après demain ou la
semaine prochaine mais il ya quand même
une autre hypothèse c'est que le
suspense dure des semaines de longues
semaines et que les deux candidats se
lancent dans une bataille juridique
s'accuse l'un et l'autre de fraude
multiplie les recours juridiques et est
là
trump a mis la cour suprême dans sa
poche qui est tout à fait républicaine
aux dernières élections c'est elle qui
avait fini par trancher
certains recours on n'est absolument pas
au bout de vos bouts de l'histoire ça
peut durer complète plusieurs semaines
et cette période en fait c'est elle et
elle a hantise de des diplomates
français en fait ces trois mois
qui sait par l'élection de la prise de
pouvoir à la maison blanche parce qu'il
ya quasiment trois mois c'est fin
janvier cette période de chaos qui
pourraient suivre si trompe décidé de
laisser de faire la politique de la
terre brûlée
et de poursuivre sa politique de
destruction en cas de victoire de joe
biden mais il y avait aussi une autre
une autre incertitude c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe si l'incertitude de si la
bataille des chiffres dure plusieurs
semaines
qu'est ce qui se passe est ce que la la
la la le combat se termine dans la rue a
cessé il ya quand même une situation
extrêmement instable à la fois
politiquement et physiquement à la
tension palpable dans les grandes villes
américaines
cette incertitude les diplomates
français qui devrait être mieux être
habitués surtout si l'europe se
désengage on comprend pas trop si les
états unis se désengage justement des
affaires du monde comme le fait depuis
longtemps de donald trump
ah oui mais parce que ce sera vraiment
c'est bon sur le fond un maiden ou un
trump mèneront la même politique
internationale c'est à dire
[Musique]
mettre la priorité en asie et sur la
chine et se retirer des affaires du
monde dans le moyen-orient et m et
peut-être retirer les troupes
américaines des endroits où elles sont
encore mais une fois une fois qu'on a
dit ça ce sera quand même très différent
pour la diplomatie française avec un joe
biden enfin souvenez-vous dès le début
de l'élection
emmanuel macron a essayé de jouer le jeu
avec donald trump il était persuadé le
président français qu'il allait pouvoir
le convaincre qu'il allait pouvoir le
faire changer d'avis à n'avions pas
marché parce que trentenaire n'a qu'une
idée en tête c'est c'est remplir ses
promesses électorales c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'il n'a pas été une des
raisons pour lesquelles n'a pas été
abandonné par par ses électeurs mais
avec joe biden ce sera quand même
beaucoup plus fluide
il y aura il y aura un retour de du
multilatéralisme des relations cordiales
pacifiée en fait en gros c'est même si
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'autonomie européenne c'est quand même
une bonne nouvelle pour la relation
transatlantique qui va pouvoir repartir
alors qu'un deuxième mandat trump là ce
sera la confirmation que c'est le fait
océans qui nous qui nous sépare est
vraiment une tempête permanente va nous
empêcher de nous de nous connecter à
l'instant le gouverneur de pennsylvanie
qui avait un gouverneur démocrate
déclare qu'il ya encore un million de
votes par correspondance et qu'il faut
encore voté et il
selon lui les déclarations de donald
trump sont une attaque partisane donc
c'est ça risque d'être d'être très très
disputé encore et on risque d'avoir
encore des dépôts lit dans les heures
qui viennent
mais oui on a dit que les votes par
correspondance était plutôt des votes
démocrates notamment parce que c'était
essentiellement les électeurs qu'ils
allaient voter avant par peur du grenat
virus et c'est plutôt le côté démocrate
un qui se méfiait du virus plutôt que le
côté républicain qui le brave mais là
encore on aura la certitude qu'en tant
les bulletins seront dépouillés mais ça
va prendre du temps ça va prendre du
temps on va nous on prend encore un
petit un petit quart d'heure un grand
quart d'heure avant de se
avant de se quitter et de façon vous
suivez tout ça sur le site du figaro sur
les relations entre macron et et trump
on a finalement bon macron a échoué à
amadouer trump c'est est ce que vous
avez dit et donc ma croûte la question
c'est est-ce que ça peut changer avec
bye donnent ce qu'ils se connaissent
d'ailleurs alors bonjour je meure en
prison ont déjà rencontré ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les équipes de
diplomate française à la fois au quai
d'orsay et à l'elysée ont été
extrêmement prudentes dans cette période
de campagne électorale de alors ils ont
évidemment ils ont tous des contacts
dans l'équipe de maiden tous les tous
les toutous les tous les jeux tous ceux
qui vont travailler avec biden dont
certains francophones sont parfaitement
connus d'aidé
des diplomates français donc on est en
terrain connu contrairement à ce qui se
passait avec donald trump
mais ils ont fait vraiment très
attention de ne pas de ne pas de ne pas
interférer dans la campagne électorale
de ne pas donner l'impression qu'il
voulait influencé qu'ils avaient fait
leur choix
une autre question qui se pose c'est si
trump et élus ou réélus ou cib hayden et
est élu vous me dit finalement que la
politique étrangère à quelques postures
prêts continue
est-ce que ce soir au ce matin plus
exactement c'est la défaite des sondeurs
déjà est ce que c'est la défaite
définitive des néoconservateurs
américains c'est à dire lesquelles la
ligue 2 expliquez-nous les 50 noir de
mal et les néoconservateurs ceux de ceux
de georges de george bush ceux de george
bush ce qu'on avait vu déjà 100 m
hillary clinton
les néoconservateurs en politique
étrangère il était trop perdu
depuis plus longtemps que ça c'est pas
ils n'ont pas perdu ce soir c'est à dire
que toute la politique qui consistait à
dire on impose la démocratie de force
notamment en irak pour qu'elle se
répande notamment au moyen-orient et que
toute cette zone instable devienne une
zone acquise à la démocratie si possible
à long terme occidentalisé
a complètement échoué depuis très
longtemps enfin sellal l'irak a été un
échec total l'afghanistan a été un échec
total
on n'impose pas la démocratie par la
force et de manière militaire d'ailleurs
on n'impose pas du tout aujourd'hui même
le soft power et même les mots ne nous
permettent plus à la démocratie de se
répandre dans le monde puisqu'elle est
plutôt dans une phase de rétractation
total y compris dans certains pays
européens qui en fait en malmène
certains de ces symboles je pense là à
la hongrie 1 et et à la pologne
tous ces pays là d'ailleurs ces pays de
l'europe de l'est du groupe devise
grades sont plutôt favorables à une
réduction de trump alors oui mais
il se il se méfie quand même te trompes
ne sais pas du tout n'a pas du tout été
très intéressés par les pays d'europe
orientale il les a de temps en temps
utilisé quand il en avait quand il avait
un intérêt cependant l'agenda politique
mais le dg intérêts européens de donald
trump qui concerne aussi la partie
orientale de l'europe
un internaute nous dit qu'est ce qu'un
internat macron vient faire là justement
on est en train de voir les relations
entre de l'administration américaine et
les pays étrangers et en particulier la
france puisque ça nous ça nous intéresse
puis quand même toujours une passion il
ya toujours une passion américaine des
relations qui sont quand même assez
complexe entre la france et les etats
unis une relation d'amour-haine revenir
sur la question d'un petit intérieur
[Musique]
donald trump donc a annoncé tout à
l'heure à avoir saisi la cour suprême
aymeric nous demande dans quelle mesure
dans quel dans quelle mesure peut être
un homme peut-il alors aymeric 10 nuits
résultats des élections avec la cour
suprême qu'est ce que la cour suprême
peut apporter en tout le cas dans ce
processus pourquoi on saisit là pour les
détails je cours je voudrais avec vaut
mieux que vous demandiez aux
correspondants mais trump a tout fait
pour que la la la la cour suprême soit
entre dans la danse
totalement totalement républicaine et
c'est toujours c'est la même chose à un
moment il ya une interprétation à donner
et le et on peut la donner dans un sens
ou dans un autre donc il espère en fait
que sont ces armées d'avocats et la cour
suprême au moment où c'est extrêmement
délicat et que c'est à quelques voix
penche du côté de des républicains
donald trump une toute dernière
peut-être question isabelle c'est
sur biden on en parlait tout à l'heure
avec une collab havraise ce qu'on ignore
c'est que dyson veut le retour du
leadership américain c'est en tout cas
le titre d'un texte qui là qu'il a signé
dans la paroisse rien faire voilà dans
la prestigieuse revue de politique
internationale
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le retour du
leadership américain en disait tout à
l'heure que les néo conservateurs sont
morts sont finis mais c'est un peu quand
même le rêve néoconservateurs ça aussi
non le leadership américain c'est pas
leur venue aux conservateurs le rav
néoconservateurs c'est en fait de faire
basculer toute une partie du monde dans
le dans le camp américain et la
démocratie américaine
le le retour de leadership de buydens
c'est un projet différent c'est à dire
c'est le retour dans le dans le système
international et le multilatéralisme
george bush
donald trump n'avait pas seulement
retirer les soldats américains du
moyen-orient il avait aussi il a aussi
retiré l'amérique de tout le système
international ce qui fait qu'elle ne
peut plus elle est effectivement à terme
on a du mal à
à avoir une influence américaine dans
l'est dans les grandes institutions
internationales dont 30 s'est retirée
donc joe biden lui veut revenir dans
toutes ses organes dans toutes ces
organisations internationales à nouveau
les promouvoir et à nouveau tisser des
liens avec ses alliés lors ce sont les
alliés européens
les alliés asiatiques les démocraties
toutes les démocraties et ça c'est le
leadership américain
peut-être un dernier point sur les
charlotte sur les dernières déclarations
les derniers états qui tombe j'ai vu que
le même le maine est tombé oui il ya